[Music]
n
oh
[Music]
call cloud and clear a proclamation of
invitation turn not on me yet I cry
the the River St lawence
[Music]
with I'm going just chill and watch
snacks in the attic I wanted to chill
with the pack and be like a young whoop
but then that would mistake me for atct
if I can imagine it's cool to give you
some advice and invite your girl to your
squadron cuz if you don't give with that
option you going to be single player
like Sovereign you going to get toss in
the bushes by King David royalty and not
a pretender detrimental to an elemental
what a avatar to a KNE Bender I got to
be me though I know it's my destiny work
too who cares if you fly if you still a
mosquito you swear you ain't something
but really be steo you like to collect
stuff and that's cool but I got bad news
even if you really was that dude King
that still be the king of the statues
since a juvenile I've been cursed with a
curse to be Musical and if you hate it
we'll meet in The Crucible other than
that is cool and it's beautiful we let
you know that your dreams are pursuable
whatever you want to do then it's doable
if you got work on a Sunday it's
suitable cuz you can listen to this in
your cubicle on the L's
day if you got work on a Sunday aable
cuz you can listen to this in your
cubicle on a L's
[Music]
day
just don't want you saying it now cuz
the mics are
hot we we respect you we respect you
just the mics are
hot yeah yeah yeah all right all right
there we go there's a time in a place
and the time right now yo I just
finished watching old dads and I just
feel like that dude in Old dad's mind I
feel like him I'm a man place I'm
Captain America boy where should I st in
we intro again what we do what we do I
never got mine oh that's true and I'm in
the middle of mine yeah so yeah let's
just start again all right welcome this
is brand new to the iore podcast we
never do this before we we just got oh
we just got here hey y'all y'all episode
number 328 another glorious Sunday we're
back at the round table on the Lord's
day and today we've got Alan Wake 2
Impressions though for those who
actually played the
game Connie Booth firing and Playstation
Studios turmoil Xbox Partners showcase
and PS5 slim internet connection
requirement to
discuss that makes me laugh every time
so we are going to get right into it so
let's introduce the four hosital gaming
those original nights of the realm here
at the round table my co Coos my brother
from another mother the difficult game
conqueror Lord of his own world and the
how oh of the young wolf my man Lord
addict back to back n he got it how we
doing sir so what's going on guys that
that's all you're getting today I feel
you I feel you we I ain't doing it again
I feel you going I know my brother's
under the weather send him some love cuz
I know he's not feeling what he's not
been feeling what so we appreciate you
holding me down y tell me why wifey text
me and said what the hell you got on
yeah that's what I said I thought why
you got a Rob he said I was like y'all
was supposed to be in the background I
said no this is my Jason costume it's my
Dicky
suit let me get my Michael Myers and
Jason oh y'all
hating no doubt and of course we have
our most technical gaming Lord the solo
gamer who lives for the single player
selfish experience and also the sastra
Davis the Lord of clarity and Lord
patreon of the iron bank PC Master rac's
own Lord Sovereign how we doing sir uh
doing good uh I absolutely did not say
this before but I will say I will say it
for the first time now I'm doing good
Mario wonder is great um you know the
the the se sound
hor sound like sound like we on a SI
cast really I sound bad you sound just
like me bro don't even get over yes hi
yeah something we gotta have uh what
What's that dude um that likes you uh uh
play my joystick
oh he can answer that you sound who
whoa I mean maybe just you
know maybe my voice is just going
through a change you know what I mean
you are not going
through you only get one of those cut
that out do a second childhood there we
go yeah so yeah like I said Mario wonder
is great continues to be great and uh
kind of a just surprises me at every
turn um Allan we'll talk about Allan
Wake did not really get to do much it
all with Alan Wake so we we we'll talk
about what we think Alan Wake our
perception perception this is topic
though it's my topic and I tell wife she
was like and and I was like
right one of those um and then
Spider-Man right I finally got I played
I did play a little bit of Spider-Man
because part of it was also that she was
disgusted by Alan Wake and that could
not be played in her presence based on
opening scenes I heard based on opening
scenes with uh men and but Hawks and yes
very termin yeah coming coming out of a
of a of a lake not good um so yeah but
Spider-Man like I said I haven't had the
issues that other people have had yet um
everything that I played so far but I'm
not super far in just uh kind of
bouncing back and forth between miles
and Peter doing some of this story stuff
um the most fun thing is just going
around the world man like again that
that World playing that uh game on
Fidelity mode with 120z on and the on is
really a sight to behold I think the
colors really pop a lot more than the
first game and just the city feels so
much more alive the density of the world
when you take into account all the the
rate tracing stuff and it's a beautiful
game and it it really it's running well
so far so I know they've patched it at
least once or twice since it launched
they patched that thing seven times bro
so maybe maybe that's that has helped
that I haven't been able to I haven't
seen any of that stuff but uh and
fingers crossed that I don't so I'm I'm
enjoying my time with that and and
hopefully get to play Alan Wake this
week at some point to wife shut that
down oh and of course shout out on the
nshs I talk about to Lord Colin lady
Micah I was not I was not able to be
there to celebrate with y'all but uh the
pictures that I did see seemed like a
joyous occasion shout out to both of you
guys congrats much love much love yeah
it was beautiful it was absolutely
beautiful you were asked about a lot I
like I appreciate that yeah what's going
on and then Jean um told all of us that
he's looking to join us at the New York
game award so he be Harold and crew so
you know so yeah I know he's going
through his treatment treatments and
stuff and shout out to H those two for
them two to make it especially by myself
with the year I've had right it's just
it was we had like a medical community
we like
yo yeah like you've been in the ER yo
I've been in the
ER it was dope that's something yeah see
all you guys there you know celebrating
with them it's been a tough year man see
hog up in the about St je Jean Jean you
know just recently hearing a little a
little bit more bad news but again he's
on the he he his spirits are high he's
going to he's going to do what he's done
since the beginning and keep fighting
you know what I mean so facts salute to
Jean no doubt and of course we have the
incredible hul of this aka the EXs gamer
oh the prophet of Xbox Swami King of the
statues who demands nothing less than
that premium experience and is the
leader of the advanced Aline movement
ooh beloved Lord King how we doing I'm
doing better than a lot of you Francis
and ganu
fans doing that I heard I heard he beat
that boy he heard wrong bro like you
know what it is I got to see this myself
I got to see this for myself this might
be boxing by us all but let's let's hear
it out all right so you know a lot of
these dudes remember when Floyd got in a
fight with Madonna and um Madonna got a
couple of hits off him the dude was like
yo he won bro he won bro I mean you know
I see someone size 15 on the you I
didn't I thought you said he got into a
fight with
Madonna like why is he beating on
Madonna when did this happen my da my da
yeah so so you know and then when tank
fought pull Cruz oh man yo pull W man he
won oh so it's like when you got
somebody that's supposed to beat
somebody you know uh and if that person
does good in any form of fashion oh he
won
bro yo you MMA dudes is so funny it's
hilarious about y'all CA y'all want that
y'all want that boxing beat so bad boy
y'all want to win that fight so bad so
listen feet was in the EG check it check
okay a knockdown don't constitute a win
I mean but he the heav he supposed to be
in the mix with right see but that's the
mentality right there okay nobody you
don't see the jab snapping this dude
head back the whole night the whole
night this dude head is like yes sir yes
sir I would like two
please and he's catching the one two
he's catching the Left Right Ango ano's
not used to having his head on a swivel
like he's yeah he's standing in front of
you trying to knock you out so so you
have the community of the MMA dudes like
he ain't supposed to go 12 rounds with
the champ boy he's not supposed to do
that he went 10 Rounds they made it a 10
round fight he went 10 Rounds with the
champ no belt was on the
line dude yo I'm not making no excuses
the dude did not he a take this dude
serious and the dude when when when the
dude dropped him cuz he dropped him you
see the drop right you see s you see it
see the
elbow Fury start doing MMA mov yeah Fury
said you going to catch the MMA elbow
you g to catch that all right listen MH
y'all got a minor victory in your heart
because y'all was looking for this
Victory with Conor McGregor y' was like
well at least Conor going to go 12
rounds with Floyd Floyd said up out of
here this is the greatest like the great
Floyd said we going to get him up out of
here Tyson Fury said I'm going 12 rounds
with this bull he ain't get no more
lucky shots we GNA jab his head back and
I had these dudes in my damn talk about
yo they robbed them no you got robbed
learn how to score a fight and you know
yo the the the most I can give Francis
mcon is seven um you know Tyson Fury got
seven rounds to three and um it was it
was like I said it was going to be a
boring fight you going to have uh mad
MMA dudes out here cheering it on I had
this one dude where I work talk about
I'm a i he's like yeah I'm going for
Francis I said you only going for him
because you're
Nigerian so he goes he goes yes I am
that's why I said he said and you should
too I said I'm not because I'm not going
to waste my money so I said how about
you bet um $200 he said you know what
I'm I'mma bet $200 king I said that's
stupid I said don't bet $200 I said he
is not going to win I said he's going to
get beat and and and Tyson Fury is going
to train for his real fight later I said
but this is just a side show this was
fun to get a check in your man hand be
happy your man getting a check so for
all you Fran and sigu fans out there be
happy your man got a
check Dana White wasn't paying him he
got there he made a good account of
himself but if he fight Deontay wild
because I heard a lot of you dud say
he'll do well with Deontay Wilder
Deontay Wilder will punch his head
Square his body so let's leave that
alone let's stop acting like he he the
next D oh Mike Tyson trainer Mike Tyson
see greatness no he didn't Mike Tyson
saw a check like I did disrespectful so
disrespectful real quick we got just
interrup you one quick shout out to jez
J go to the chat gifted 10 iron Lord
members
yo membership of the CH window Cal out
to what up appreciate you brother appr
like that little boy I love
that very proper very Posh very Posh so
what I'm playing right now I'm playing
um Mario Wonder yo this is the wildest
slate of games that I'm playing all at
one time uh Dead Space remake shout out
to Game Pass will let me eat nice um
Assassin's Creed
Mirage
fortnite um oh I I I went back to play
uh that um the the racing game um no not
not the forza the crew the crew I went
back to the crew because they had added
something in there and I had to go check
it to make sure it was right and it does
run better because they had a update on
some other stuff to it I was like oh yo
so I went back to that um and then I'm
playing
Spider-Man all right so I got the code
for Alan Wake I said okay let me install
while I'm inall that let me get to
Spider-Man let me finish this game since
they said it's this the you know the
five to eight hours first of all you
dudes are liars yeah dudes are Li this
game ain't no five to eight hours I
literally played this game 8 to 10 hours
straight hardcore nah I'm at a place in
the game though where I hopefully I'm
about to see the end of the game I'm at
the end game part of the game and I'm
fighting the final form of the final
boss so I think right um I'm in love
with these characters
I've been in love with with comic books
my whole life this Journeys have taken
me to different places and I encapsulate
all three stories how they supposed to
be all three stories is absolute love I
love this last story this last story is
impeccable um the problems with the bugs
is a problem right and I I encountered
another bug and this is the bike bug if
anybody's gotten the bike bug where the
front of the bike is in the ground and
it's on a time up part it's
disheartening and then I got to another
bug where somebody said I think it was
amazing Lucas said it you had to do a a
move is a prom and I know this is the
same place because it led me to the same
frustration I had to reload from that
checkpoint there because it absolutely
crashed it the game would not continue
the screen was frozen and the music was
still playing it was just horrible at
that point but again I like how they put
all the pieces of the to the puzzle of
the story together and I and I want to
say to people that feel like they lost
characters oh you know this character is
dead and that character is dead and they
shrink in the world no this is a story
in comic books they tell stories so this
is not the end of let's say uh um one of
the villains who died this is just a
story and then when they tell a story
again that's why they reset a lot your
character be back so this is not you
know it's not real life I see a lot of
people complain about that that
Insomniac is killing off characters in
this world this world is not going to
live in perpetuity they're going to
start over and do another game it's
going to be another Spider-Man it's
going to be another thing so the game is
fantastic it does stay at a eight for me
because the bugs keep removing me from
the enjoyment but the story so good
Insomniac is I man I love I love their
story writing and it's really good I
hate the Mary Jane missions by the way
other than that crazy no it's just
stupid get it out of the game it felt
like Last of Us
gimped
yeah so she she got a little more
gangster from she learned from Silver
Sable right like apparently she's so
that's what I I heard it was oh it's
better he's like still out the game it's
it's it's Last of Us gimped like you
don't have all the weapons or whatever
and I know not made to be like that
she's supposed to feel um weak and
helpless in that moment because you're
so omnipotent with the Spidey right so
it's supposed to ground you into how it
feels to being a human dealing with the
hunters or whatever else that she's
dealing with but at the moment though I
can't stand her face and I can't stand
her so the character itself is an
annoyance her face is an annoyance and
the m is an annoyance and it should be
optional to skip her stuff because it
leads to absolutely nothing in the game
fair enough fair enough a lot of people
spoke I looked at the developer tried to
I think he doubled down was like we
don't give a f I know he don't I was
like yo I never SE that's why but the
sales reflected though oh damn here we
go yeah yeah y'all didn't do 2.4 million
but we going to get to that when I get
to my SE we going talk about what you're
really doing that's not part of
discussion
today going move on and of course next
time listen to
us we have the gaming ninja himself this
[__] don't be look Cito spr that real
the I Fe I tell you what you want to
hear what you need to hear shout out to
Lord cin shout out to Mama Micah the the
The Royal Wedding you know what I'm
saying fresh off the plane it was
fantastic so many people I got a chance
to see and you know we talked earlier
just seeing you know hog and Je Park and
you know what I'm saying what about your
look though bro I mean you know we had
the
cor C that situation you know what I'm
saying I had to come Keep it Gangster
Keep it Gangster keep
ganger I have been doing little ganger
Bo On The Dance Floor yeah you need to
you needed to turn you take off the
jacket and roll up the sleeves oh see
that's too much I a want to kill him
like that I didn't want to kill him like
that it wasn't it wasn't ready let me
ask you a question so did you walk that
you was you was part of the groom no no
I was part of the home yeah oh so you
didn't get to walk down
the
hey so we ain't got no dance floor
footage or you just there is Dance Floor
footage of me there is Dance Floor
footage of me cuz that what it is is
that after the the corporate Co wne was
flowing right and then it was a couple
people the song started coming on and
they start grabbing me up it's like come
on Co let's go my wait wait so what was
your song what Was Your Song though they
had it was it was they they had limited
selection for a person like me you know
cholate
chocolate the best I could do give y'all
was a little little John Turned Down For
What I okay I know that one I know that
one you know what I'm saying I was like
they had a little Usher what is it the
yeah was it yeah yeah that you know the
typical wedding joint oh Air Force on
you had a little
[Laughter]
bit oh and you had some Andre 3000 you
know no we we did not have that
wewa no no they had they had you they
had your back street boys for you they
had that okay oh
yeah back the only
one the one where they yeah yeah
everybody that one yeah
that's said everywhere everybody
everybody back street Bo all right that
was I was like yeah that's the next song
so wait a second y'all didn't do a line
y'all didn't get the whole no no but I
will say there was a couple of females
in there that was that was a little
extra lit when certain songs
came I was oh that's her song that's my
neck my back they was not playing that
moving on shout out to again shout out
call Mori the moris doing their thing
you know what I'm saying shout out to
the whole LSM fam everybody Dustin again
Maddie and Chris we missed you and um
but it was definitely a corporate car
kind of affair it was very cool very
very very pleasant very put it down for
ILP that's my guy no doubt you already
know and uh yeah that's been pretty much
me as far as gaming not much because
I've been traveling so Starfield on to
go all day every day close to getting
working on my thousand my gamer score on
the new game plus I'm rocking all that
and then u a little bit of um Jesse
season loss with the Halloween joint and
that's been pretty much it so you want
to get these super chats so yeah it
funny I tried to jump I said let let me
hit this Tekken V to see see if it's
still around it shut me down he was like
this does not
exist yeah yeah they shut that down what
El we got all right we got hindsight
with hustle member for
22 what's good y'all what up hustle
blessings there we got David hot rght
member for 24 months Lord Silva happy
Lord's day thank you brother appreciate
you salute then we have my name is mud
$5 Jack how about those reaching hard
with the lack of Xbox reviews on
Metacritic for Allan Wake 2 have they
not paid attention to every third party
review I I didn't realize that they
weren't any specific sort of uh Xbox
reviews it was mostly PlayStation I
guess
PC um yeah all right then like like
ascog said welcome to the realm Lord J
Cordon Lord bronze shout out for gifting
10 IOP membership and then he also sent
a 5B Super Chat o what's
this shout out to you Jess salute Jess
appreciate you brother let's put the
crest in the chat for midnight Druid for
gifting five IOP memberships appreciate
that salute and we got Gerald Mack the
homie also gifting five IOP memberships
let's put the crust in the chat man yeah
yeah and that's it we are caught up for
now we got a lot of Paton questions so
we got to get going um veto can't
pronounce your name uh uh Shante I be to
say that's what I think it is he said he
said that's what I think it is that's
what I think it is apologies if I buchet
it well will probably be covered anyway
but any personal experiences or Thoughts
with Sarah as I think that's as yes that
has as the head of Xbox would be cool
only recent recently watching Xbox
content regularly I don't know anything
about the history so he wants to know
how he feel about Sarah Bond being the
head of Xbox and then just about you
know the history of Xbox in general with
us so we want to set it off Sol I think
I don't know if Alex is away for
something I mean I we'll talk about it
later I guess might as well just talk
about it now but it's it's uh it's
important it's important it is uh kind
of a historical moment right first time
we have a woman and specifically a woman
of color in at the at the helm of a
major first party um yeah she's in
charge of everything now when it comes
to the hardware side moving forward um
and Matt booty obviously on the Bethesda
zenx side um so this is very important
as I've stated in the past I I wish we
lived in a world where it wasn't
important where this would be the the
hundredth time we've seen this happen
but it's not unfortunately so we so it
it needs to be acknowledged it needs to
be celebrated and she's worked very hard
to to sort of be in this position this
is something kind of that the entire
Community saw coming uh in some way
shape or form and allows Phil to move
kind of handle more of the broader scope
of the business right and the marketing
budget now and the marketing
exact
done you crazy so it's it's a it's
definitely an important thing shout out
to her shout out to Matt uh but it is uh
congratulations to them and it's a very
very important moment in the in the
history of gaming because it has not
happened before true and it's not over
baby like yo if you looked at the list
it was 50% of them were women right so
um you know and it was the people that
held the line like I told y'all dudes
before he went around the table you know
at the end you know we sitting there we
are part of a team you know y y'all know
that scene with the famous scene with
the baseball
B and on this team you know we were Roy
camaraderie right and you know she held
it down matt held it down everybody held
it down the people that haven't held it
down are out Bobby definitely out hind
is definitely out once emails came out
and they was like oh you so you're a
confidential inform oh come on don't do
Fe don't do unle feet like that
sympathizing with the other side don't
do I no we going to do them just like
that that's a legend be respectful a
legendary flogged in the street you got
to get up out of here ridiculous it's
it's cool go work for them but um
ridiculous I love the fact that you know
um to be honest with you those people
cuz all her all her conversation or her
stance around it was we don't give up
yeah we fight all the way to the last
breath and that's the person that you
want in charge of something in in your
team that's the people that you want in
that Foxhole that you look over to they
you want those people that is going to
fight with every utensil you know I
wasn't surprised with Matt getting the
raise that he got over you know and
where he's at um because his mentality
is kill or be killed and and and and I
know people say you know King stop using
warlike terms when it comes to things
this corporate stuff is serious you talk
about trillion doll companies and they
and a lot of their bonuses is tied to
Performance all right so that's the
incentive that you get like on any
football team or Squad based team a lot
of their contracts is tied to
Performance saa's you know contract as
far as certain things on Game Pass is
tied to Performance and growth and I saw
people laughing at the fact that they
didn't reach the internal uh numbers of
78% in growth that they wanted and they
only reached 28% what type of animal
does you think that makes him to reach
that
78% you you really have to think about
the mentality of the individual who is
incentivized by winning these
individuals are incentivized by winning
so she gets this great promotion because
this deal goes through and her efforts
were rewarded she did a thing in AB so
you got to look at it you got to see it
for what it is so now that they got a
taste of Victory and winning just Mak
some a greater Beast going forward and
his wins are not going to stop so
allowing Phil to have the ability to to
give all these guys the marketing budget
to do stuff and y'all asked all the time
oh uh when is Microsoft going to start
marketing in my regions I see a lot of
buses driving around with Starfield on
it so remember this this win as far as
her win too but I'm talking about the
whole team that was on that list that
got promotions and and and everything
got reconfigured and is showing their
appreciations for the people that was in
the struggle are holding the line and
now advancing the line forward I salute
you guys for definitely being uh what we
asked y'all to be and all y'all dudes
that said all I want with Microsoft is
to be better and
compete now what's
up I feel you yeah look I mean I'm going
to add on to what you said and let's add
back um yeah I think it's uh she worked
extremely hard it's a huge deal um as
far as you know obviously I've had the
pleasure meeting the queen a few times
and taking some pictures and um yeah I
love her energy it's her passion for
gaming speaks for itself especially with
Sega in uh Japanese games I sense the
passion there um I think it's an
inspiration for young for young black
girls to to see that especially in
gaming when you don't see a lot of women
of color black women specifically you
know in in roles like that I think it's
important I think it's important but
more importantly she's qualified for the
role and she's put in the work so that's
what it's about to be and I think what
you said King is resonates because I
think this is all part of the ABK
transitioning and and inclusion so that
hopefully that everyone has clear cut
roles now booty is going to have also
Bethesda and zenax the head of them
report to him so what I'm looking at is
this eliminates potentially redfall
situations where you don't know what's
going on over there because you were
just isolated over here kind of thing
and I think that's going to be important
for ABK cuz you know the real work
starts down they've got all these
Studios they got all these major
franchises it's a lot of work ahead but
I think maybe to what you're saying Phil
and them had this plan as far as
rewarding and having a new
infrastructure going forward so salute
to them I think that's um that's dope
and uh yeah that's pretty much all I got
unless add back I think he's still he's
not feeling well I'll move on to the
next one um Stitch uh he says let's talk
about it once again we can clearly see
how the media is afraid to talk bad
about s games do you all think the
reviews for b no he ain't call bugman 2
should had should had mentioned all the
issues that the game have based on
preview statements made about Starfield
not getting nominated for Game of the
Year based on the issues at launch
bugman 2 should not be part of the game
of the year nominees as well so what's
your what's your thoughts on this I'll
take
it definitely definitely um first of all
I don't think it was going to get
nominated as game of the year but you
know being that you know these
journalist is Sony stands it probably
will get nominated because that's the
only game they put out this year uh the
fact of the matter is if you're going to
say bugs are in other games and you give
them hits for launch then you should to
now what this this is the the excuse
that they're using well in my review
copy I didn't have it and then after it
launched uh update went up and then it
messed it up for you guys so my review
is going to stand because I played it in
this state and not the horrible state
you played it in I don't believe you
like I don't believe you right because
all the streamers that I saw put up
every streamer had ran into the same
bugs that I ran into and you're gonna
say again King when it went live it was
a bug that they put in the game okay so
then you should just erase your score
and start over again and then if you
experience bugs note that then put that
up but you won't do it and we understand
that you have to save Kong I get
I I get it K
versus yeah I get it but you know who's
the real king of the mon is and it's
going to be a point in time y can't run
for it but I see what y'all doing and I
like it but yeah it should be hit for
those scores uh for the bugs and it
shouldn't be nominated no okay uh s your
thoughts on bug man oh that's ad back
okay yeah just I know you're not feeling
well you sent me like this certain type
of rubber in the buy and I was explain
Zachary what it is oh yeah you got to
get that right that t you got to get
that Tess baby yeah um I don't know what
we're doing talking about all right so
we talk about now we talk about uh
Spider-Man 2 as stitches call it bugman
2 and he's saying that um that he says
it's a clear bias because Starfield not
getting nominated for Game of the Year
based on the technical issues and then
he's saying that but Spider-Man
shouldn't be part of it as
well
um I think you get argument why both
shouldn't be part of it but at the same
time I don't think that's realistic
these are two big games that came out
this year they're both definitely you
know in conversations with that now I
mean you can you can put up a bug on
Starfield I could put up a bug on on
um on Spider-Man we could keep doing
this forever because
they I experien bugs in Starfield and I
experienced a game baking bug that that
game breaking
bug I didn't experience nothing like
that when I played Spider-Man but I can
H say besides that one hiccup playing
Starfield I was more annoyed playing
Spider-Man uh because for the most part
my experience playing Starfield was
Flawless there wasn't really too many
technical issues I had some here and
there but when I was playing
Spider-Man it wasn't gamebreaking stuff
because I I I feel gamebreaking stuff is
when you stuck and you can't any further
right yep but I had a lot of annoying
stuff that was happening in Spider-Man
it's like I said if it wasn't for the
checkpoint system I'd have dropped it
that's how bad it was but the checkpoint
system made it to where even if I was
having those issues resetting a
checkpoint only brought me back not far
at
all no doubt no I feel you on that
definitely on the progression solve
thoughts on the uh bugman 2o it's
stitches like I said I haven't had the
bugs yet so I can't speak I'm not going
to say that I have because I haven't um
and then Starfield is largely you know
when we were playing in the preview
period I like I said I had on PC I had a
crash to desktop like a lot of times but
I never had any in-game bugs per se that
uh prevented me from from progressing or
anything like that it would just I I
knew from the beginning and this is a
Bethesda thing I don't know you guys do
it but I save scum in Bethesda games to
be on the so I I you know I always do
that so um yeah I didn't have any bugs
during gameplay except maybe you know
just every now and again NPC's a bald
and stuff like that like other than that
so for
me that was funny that was a funny one
yeah so I mean for me like to me the
game is such it you have to be you have
to be let let's keep the same energy as
we always say if Starfield is being
docked for that and that's the that's
the Hill somebody's dying on then that
should be the same Hill you stand on for
Spider-Man oh um I my personal belief is
they both should be nominated for Game
of the Year still because they're both
great products at the end of the day I I
feel like starf is going to get the
shaft oh you agree with rain especially
especially on that especially with Allan
weight coming up heard
outside
even even with Adam way coming out I
still think Starfield is going to get it
I think I I think legistic wise it just
makes more sense for him business to
have that and I'm not saying that you
know Jeff Keeley gonna make sure that
that's in the in but I think he's gonna
be very vocal you know it would be
awesome you know you get that all three
thees that come to to life like it be
awesome if everybody had a game if he's
smart wink wink funny we are we are
literally talking about any game it
doesn't matter what gets on there
they're not
winning so I it something yeah like to
me again have the same energy you know
you have to keep the same energy let's
do that let's not be let's not be
Hypocrites now but again we're talking
about the internet here so to Spider-Man
W I might be asking too much it's not
it's not it's not oh that that would be
egregious across the board that would be
egregious it's not it's not that's not
that's not even in the conversation of
it is it already won in my heart is not
gonna win I think I think with a with a
Zelda and a balers out there n no it's
not even close Starfield somehow got on
and one God it would be blood the street
they would be blood the street to the
streets would be crazy be crazy yeah be
it would be an interesting site I will
say that that be funny um yeah the chat
real quick put in the chat I obviously
I'm ask you guys do a little research
but I'm not doing it I don't feel good
tell go and find out on Twitter when
they announced last year's
nominations what day was it because I
think it was in November sometime but I
do not have the energy to go look right
now so are you good people go look
please please thank anyway I ain't got
to add too much I pretty much said
everything else look you know I had
experience you know with uh Spider-Man
the same way so you know it's I agree
with King that theoretically you should
re-review your thing if the product
comes out and it's different but to you
know we we know how the industry works
and it's it's not doing that and and In
fairness to Starfield yeah it's not the
same energy we just got to say that's
the truth so you know hopefully you know
both get nominated I still like both
games so that's pretty much all I got to
say when I don't really got too much to
care about that I know dudes is is in
the streets for this one though all
right so we got uh
subb ain't let me super chat but that's
why I'm here I just wanted to say these
Sony Ponies are for the streets but we
are for the stars all in fun shout out
to the Lords and hope y'all have a great
episode all
right patreon just for smoke he wanted
to get his bars off all right dip down
is back so you better get ready you know
I got to save the world dip down ain't
happening dip Downer we oer I think we
saved the world one time we Sav one one
time we saved the here dip down our
leading patreon drama Creator uh so no
extra allies to fight the dragon however
the dimensional Dragon agrees to Grant
you any video game weapon of your choice
if you can all agree what is the best
Sony first party IP of all time if able
what's your weapon if we if we decide
agree I guess on the IP then we pick the
weapon and place it says PS King I'm
back on fortnite getting these chicken
did this where you at that's that's
you're
lying it just at me and I'll get at you
um so I was confused they said we pick a
weapon or we no we got to yeah sorry no
we have to pick the best IP that's in
the Sony lineup and after we come to the
consensus of the best IP then the dragon
will grant us a one weapon yeah and okay
so my I know I know we're not going to
agree on this I know where you going
saying Last of Us Part Two so we we we
it's IP he says IP so we can say Last of
Us yeah so I won't say that I know you
won't um and I'm gonna say this
right I know Sony has a ton of ips that
are are beautiful there's some dead
franchises that us older heads is going
to hearken back to and then you know for
the newer guys it's going to be uh some
stuff I'm going to say I'm going to have
to say is The Last of Us and the only
reason why I'm going to say is the last
of us and it redefined Sony as a brand
yes that's literally the OG of hashtag
just one that's like of it because
Naughty Dog Neil duckman's thought with
this game is so humanizing the story can
be told on various different mediums it
could be read it could be shown in video
games it could be shown through movies
um the game transcends all different
forms of media and and it also
elaborates and expounds on different
forms of conversation on how you feel
about it and I thought he was Fearless
from the beginning till now right so you
know having the police officers and
stuff go out and you know kill citizens
because of stuff that they know in the
background that's actually happening and
to to deal with it and wrestle with
stuff and you know the the the thought
of um being a s get parent to a child
that's not yours that is important to
the mission and you lost your kid it's a
whole weave and web about it that makes
it the greatest um IP for me so
hopefully I did uh plead my case but I'm
pretty sure we're not going to to decide
on this as far as the best IP for them
so I I'm I'm I'm curious to hear addicts
one um I'm pretty much probably know
what uh Cognito is going I don't know
what Sal is going my m God of
War God of War just in my personal
opinion it's the most unique title
they've had that stood out all these
years it's the only new God of War or
the old franchise God of War is a
franchise okay uh it's one of the only
IPS that I know of um you know I'm not
saying there isn't others but it's one
of the biggest IPS I could think of that
had a complete redirection in gameplay
and
succeeded uh you know most most most
companies would love to do that and
there's not a lot that have done that
successfully uh so that's why you know
and I feel like God of War I is the best
action adventure game in existence so
God of War I M okay okay no doubt we got
God of War we got Last of Us Sol where
do you land in with the dragon and
saving the world okay so one question so
we're not counting Spiderman as a Sony
IP right I mean I guess we could it's
not their IP though so we got to talk
about their IP
okay they don't own that you trying to
eliminate fair that is fair they they
own the Spider-Man IP so let's get rid
of that let's go to Us's go to where you
going for real now oh Lord so if so if
that is the case we're not doing that
then
yeah so I in a lot of ways my answer
would have been what Kings is because it
is it's the IP that is transcended and
it's the one that they they're going to
see success in on a lot of different
fronts the game front obviously we've
seen the success on the the TV front
that it's going to be a multi-m winning
uh show um but then you got to look at
GT GT is their best GT is their
bestselling franchise period really I
didn't realize that
so got a movie too yeah the movie the
movie is not Last of Us
quality I got go with King though I
think I mean it's my personal love for
the IP and I just think that it has
elevated to that point where it's like
it's still not going to be for everybody
it's not going to sell like Gran Turismo
because it's you know the the level of
violence and murder is not going to be
for everybody um but I do think it just
it is the one that has the ability to be
most successful on multiple fronts if
they ever do get this factions out they
might be successful on the multiplayer
side that's what ice that's one I I
almost I almost said unchartered cuz I
feel like like even though I'm not the
biggest fan of the franchise I think you
can make an argument that like the
Uncharted franchise is one of the key
factors that led to PlayStation coming
back because because without unch
charger I don't think you get to that
get that last of us because unch charger
kind of evolved to last absolutely and
I'm not sure Uncharted is sold more than
last of us if I'm not mistaken because
they had they've had more games they've
had more games and again I think it is
just more accessible where not everybody
is going to especially what people heard
from last of us too that it was just
it was super it was super dark right and
people like the you know the sort of the
Indiana Jones style sort of piness of
Uncharted um but I I I kind of agree
with Kingo because again they had the
movie and it was successful it was it
was pretty successful um we'll see if
they bring it back maybe it has that
type of pull if they bring it back which
I think they are going to bring back
with with obviously uh Nate's uh
daughter
maybe I still got to go with last of us
though I feel that yeah they I mean it
it's all of them can make an argument as
far as their their IPs they're that good
um if I was trying to say the world i'
just agree with ja last us just to save
it but um I can't get mad at that since
I don't care I care I care I mean I mean
I know where he's going I know where he
going you know where I'm going yeah I
know where you going there only one IP
that I like it's not a franchise yet
it's it's one it's a brand new and when
he come outside and when he come back
you know what's about to happen yeah so
you know where I'm at with
this the world is going to end what
weapon what weapon would you have chose
though I would have chose the BFG that's
exactly what I would have chose the BFG
The BFG yeah I yeah I would have chose
was BG BMG is classic so the BG or the
um no uh what the hell what what's the
one that from Gears where they they rain
down from the oh the oh the
ham ham dud but the top the problem with
the hammer Dawn is you got to put in the
coordinates like yeah you got hold on
y'all you go what you go what's your ref
I don't know to be honest with you that
or or the or or or the fat boy from um
um Fallout
oh yeah I forgot about that yeah
the that's crazy no doubt so we died
again dip down we died again sorry okay
so here here's a list of the most
powerful weapons and this is not
anything it's by the gamer number one
the master sword number two the blue
shell in
Mario number three the hidden blade in
Assassin okay what the energy sword in
Halo 2 oh bfg9000 from Doom keyblade
from Kingdom Hearts Blades of
chaos the
Pokeball let me see what else and then
it then it cuts who the hell put this
list together wild this is this is from
where from game ran I think it was the
gamer it was the gamer leave that gameer
dude alone because you stand I want you
stand in the middle of the street your
master sword at any point in time pause
and I'm going to stay with the BFG and
you just get ready they got the golden
gun and golden eye let me see what else
take the mystery
box oh we good yeah so we de okay
cool user not found that's his name hey
Lords hope you're all having a good day
so far my question is since Starfield
has released and we've all had a chance
to sink a lot of time into it was there
a discovery you made in the game that
really wowed you things like a hidden
outcome to a quest a strange Discovery a
random encounter a specific creature
Planet perhaps stuff along those lines
but the important thing is that it made
you feel like you truly discover
something that no one else had PS addict
I remember one time you said you wish
there was some ref refences to Bethesda
games other universes in Starfield where
apparently some have now been found the
easiest most clear ones are the box of
sweet rolls on Grandma's ship that say
they are the tastiest treat in any
universe and in a certain prison no
spoilers the name of a random prisoner
that was locked up is Delvin mallerie
there was a removed deep Elder Scrolls
law Easter egg creature that would have
been found in the maoc system do with
that what you will sorry for the long
question just also quickly want to thank
you guys for all the great content if I
can only watch one podcast live in a
week I always try to make it IOP on
Sunday salute using now found that's
what's up appreciate that's what's up so
uh yeah anything we found that was a
truly wowing Discovery in Starfield
anybody go add um I found this white a
version of this monster that is like
this unbeatable beast on the first
planet oh yeah so um and I only found
that uh because I was on him her and the
guest uh show with uh C money uh and and
his wife so they they talked about this
monster and I was like I gotta find this
monster for myself right so it wasn't a
discovery of my own per se it was a
discovery of somebody else's but I I
found the monster and as the level I am
I was like I should easily beat this
monster well easily not easily easily
not this this creature is tenacious oh
and you don't care that I got powers so
um yeah so it's it's it's yeah stuff
like that I I don't know it's it's I
find the game amazing from the little
stuff that I'm able to do for no reason
in the planet I I'm just this weirdo
that found out that once you destroy a
ship they Parts fall to the planet and
you could go to the planet and get some
more wreckage so I don't know I like it
like that weird addict your wowing
moment in Starfield found an abandoned
space shuttle once that had that had um
a companion that was locked up there to
this day I still can't find her I left
her there yo I never found you left her
there that's crazy I I was doing
something else and like I had to pass a
check to even talk to her because she
was going to shoot me oh and when I
passed
it it gave me the opportunity to let her
come on because she her ship was was was
uh destroyed so it was like just
hovering in space and and I left her
there that's an adct thing to do adct
thing to do yeah she was like I just
need the these certain items to get back
up and running and I'm like yeah but I
need those items too so just here so you
g to stay here that's wow salute work it
out work it out I took everything in her
in her ship too peace peace you need
more stuff I respect the Beast of
savager so I haven't I haven't done
enough story stuff to really be wowed by
stuff like that I've been the idiot that
just goes planet to planet just try to
see what's on there oh yeah so I the
most that I found is just going into
caves really and seeing some idiot who's
in
there ah I'm dying leave one of them was
like just leave me here I'm like all I
just can give you this medicine you can
go
no y all right so stuff like that um
just just exploring different uh
different planets like and or or you
know one of those places that has been
taken over by Pirates or something like
that and in each one the story is a
little bit different like the hierarchy
of the Pirates the reason that they're
there the beefs that they have with them
with themselves is a little bit
different um but yeah that's the sort of
stuff that I I found so far I think and
to King's Point I did also find on the
first planet that I landed on I was
killing everything until this one
creature was like nah and I I didn't
realize it and I'm shooting at it and
he's like yeah level 23 and
I'm different yeah so so stuff like that
yeah for me it was um I a few but the
one it was like this deric ship and like
when you get on it everybody's bodied
Massac in brutal way what and then you
go and it's oh and I thought the game
glitched cuz I run with my companion all
the time right right so I'm like all
right so I was like a Doran fan where
you where you at like so I kept going
back to my ship after I docked on to
this deric ship and the game is like no
you're doing this by yourself yourself
so I said okay and yeah when I was there
and it's you just you get going on
terminals and the life support system
went down and I'm like yo what is bro K
why this game turned into alien
isolation what and I'm like hey
yo this is what happened on the sh yeah
you found you found creature yeah you
you you keep venturing and it and this
thing is ridiculously op compared to
your level luckily I had some serious
Weaponry you know what I mean that I had
aced but I had to still cheese it I had
to cheese it so I could get through like
it was it was crazy and it will hunt you
down through the whole joint it is know
I said oh this is why everybody got
murdered yeah yeah yeah it's I I didn't
enounter that yeah it's a little deric
[__] but you you say that hell and
nobody answer and you get on and you
just everywhere you go there scientists
everyone is brutally murdered it's crazy
and it's quiet and you can't bring your
companion I I like stuff like that me
too I was I was like this is crazy I
like yeah that jint is fine anyway let's
get into the poll that was the last one
shout out to everybody patreons is
really doing their thing salute to the
patreon question all right last week's
poll we got some stuff up in patreon
this week shout out to me and adct yes
reactions we did the um the what is it
what is that thing called adct battle um
death B death battle yeah we did some
death battles with some anime stuff some
real good stuff yeah y'all killing it
y'all killing it salute to y'all on the
pat King reacted to Mo yuch versus S
Eisen oh Lord yeah and Jason versus
Michael
Myers yeah and for the whole show I wore
um who I thought was going to win the
fight so you know cuz you know cuz I got
both mad so like like today I was I
didn't know who I was going to be I was
going
be you messing anyway oh it's got to be
Michel may remember is the month of
shober for you I don't know yeah shock
we get these joints going on um to the
question uh last week's po results are
in the Starfield with Starfield winning
MPD for the month of September and
already being the seventh best selling
game or 2023 year to date which factor
do you most attribute to its success the
winner four-way I poll at 36% of the
vote very close y'all PC day and date
promoting more sales growth group coming
in tied for a second tied we having a
tide a while
26% Xbox game pass is not catabolizing
sales and user reviews are greater than
uh Media review disparity on the
enjoyment of Starfield so that those two
came in as a tie and then um in last
place where only 10% of the vote was I
don't care y'all better Bend IN need to
God Howard start humming that theme song
for Star shout out to the LW who who
participated King the the realm says PC
day and date was uh the major
factor well that that [__] that [__]
happened in in across the board with
everybody I think PC should be the
outlier and let's see how the games feel
on that uh platform it is a major fact
that when it comes to selling games and
getting games across to a larger
audience because as we know PC dudes
really engage in the products and and
they want our um you know products that
are first party from both um you know
companies Sony and Microsoft so yeah
it's a major contributing factor and I
think going forward it will continue to
be
S no doubt no doubt that's it Sol any
super chats before we get into the topic
so we good we got to pay the bills we
got to do anything we got to do yeah we
got to read the super chats and then pay
some bills just do that afterward so uh
we got Homeless Bird $5 Super Chat
that's funny feel better addict you can
always visit my bay Dr teemi and she'll
set you right Don't Fear the Reaper he
will be waiting for you I'm like okay I
don't know what that mean I do you have
any sound like an anime is an anime
reference or something that's from
say oh yeah yeah I I definitely romanced
her it's kind of weird cuz like you're
like 15 16 and she's like a 30y old but
W she got
romance she got I'm done yeah that back
in the day I I I Romance the teacher too
so
I think I think I Ro everyone that
wasn't my age
I I just got my 11y old nephew that
game oh you know my son is playing that
game right
now they'll be fine they don't show
nothing like like that n just give any
Windows
bro in in terms of like the the romances
from other games is definitely like a PG
version of
it like it's like Boulders gate be
showing
everything that's why yall like Boulders
gate all I hear is y like Boulders gate
for the fact that it's some stuff that's
going on there with animals now there's
more visualization and this is why your
perverts say oh that's
SC ridiculous you're able to do nasty
things you're ridiculous
Ty Petty there we have e easy with the
$5 Super Chat what's up Lords hope
everyone is doing good is jaffy still
coming jaff on coming pause I don't
know is sorry I read it isff still
coming
on come on y got to Y got to relax
acting like I know standby he's on
standby he's coming like I know that we
have do Strange Love $2 Super Chat Cog
Cog was swinging meat on the
FL
yo yo you are doing the most right now
son then we have zip Davis $5 Super Chat
every time someone says zip when talking
about Spider-Man 2 Marvel pays me a
dollar I'm Gonna Be Rich keep it up guys
o
we
Z then we have Mr to opinionated $5
Super Chat Xbox is promoting women and
Playstation is walking them out
Jesus
[Music]
wow whoa that's crazy then we got luci's
Augustus member for 26 months Lord BR
funny how Pete Hines left before the
news of the restructuring he didn't want
to rock the book of X okay okay well you
can leave
sir a book of X thing that's what it was
all right all
right then we have THX 1138 $2 Super
Chat Matt will spend them out of
business yes that is that is Matt
Booty's Mantra we'll spend them into the
ground King's man that's right get him
out of
here uh then we have Danny passion
official with the $5 Super Chat and this
is something that I've been hearing
lately as well so maybe I'm the only one
but I think that isn't it isn't cool
being interrupted with YouTube ads on a
live streaming show come on yeah they
bugging today sorry I actually I've been
seeing more more shows it does seem like
they're starting to push ads during live
shows yeah yeah they want they want
people to purchase the premium product
so so that that is what they're doing um
then we have masokista $2 Super Chat the
reviews for Spiderman's Spiderman's are
1,00%
inflated I don't like that name we got
to move on
Spiderman's thing is there's still
people having issues with buffering in
the chat yeah yeah me too here I was
like okay well maybe they could go and
the people that's having issues go watch
it on um on Twitch yeah and I looked
over there at like twitch I don't know
what twitch is doing either like
something goinging it's all good yeah so
shout out to we're being a cyber
attacked what else we got uh let's put
the CR in the chat for member for 14
months Craig holig again Craig Hol again
we got CRA again like with the $5 Super
Chat business now the stari landed
didn't hit a home run what do we want to
see in outer Worlds 2
oo I would say that um Starfield has
pains me to say this cuz but is I mean
obsidian my my dudes but Starfield or
from the companion side has up them now
they had I felt outter worlds had it in
the beginning that no one was really
doing it like them but they took it a
step further so they going to have to
step they join up and then yeah they
don't got to do the whole big world it
seems like some people still want a
condensed you know Hub world yeah I
don't think it will be that I don't
think they've already said yeah they
they've most likely going to switched
that direction based on I'm assuming
from like how they talked about a vow
they want to stick to what they do best
so yeah I
agree yeah so let me see then we got
Halo Reach around5
super addict what are your coordinates
trying to give you my hammer of dwn
yo
yo man I can't hear
nothing back to you up adct what's going
on who you who you impressing out here
that's that's probably my girl on the
burner no see see that's when you that's
when you hope that and you and you go
back in the room be like babe you're so
funny with that that message that you
put what message you wait that was Halo
Reach who this Halo Reach wow okay they
they got your favorite game reaching
around pause he documented
documented wow okay
that's the end of that so it's it's a
perfect
transition into our next segment here so
we go pay some bills I will ask the Lord
not to mute their mics because I'll be
coming to them for a moment uh
so gentlemen Across the Nation I have an
urgent message for you this episode of
The Iron Lords podcast is brought to you
by manscaped the brand that took your
balls to space is now launching them
into the the ultra sphere introducing
the lawnmower 5.0 Ultra featuring a new
Cutting Edge design and Next Generation
dual skin safe blade heads for different
shaves it's pretty much a spaceship to
take your boys downstairs to the next
level join the 9 million men worldwide
who trusted manscaped with the brand new
the lawnmower 5.0 Ultra by going to
manscape.com for 20% off plus free
shipping with the code iron Lords
Hightech for Low Places manscaped so as
I said to you guys last week it's not
time for games not time for innuendo
none of that we having none of that
today we go directly to the source the
Lords of the round table and find out
what their experience has been with the
manscaped 5.0 Ultra package so let's go
to Lord Cognito first freshly off the
airplane freshly quaffed you know did
what did you use to prepare yourself for
for the for the beauty that you
exhibited during said wedding yesterday
that lawn mow was official so in case
you know the the Royal loins had to be
handled you know what I'm saying shout
out to the lawm 5.0 it's amazing you
know what I'm saying this thing is very
light very cool waterproof you get right
after the shower you know what I'm
saying handle the nether regions handle
make sure your master sword is right you
know what I'm saying just in case things
pop off after the weather you know what
hey hey we got to keep it we got to keep
it real you with another to it could go
down it could go down so make
sure exactly you beep make sure that you
you know before you pregame you went in
there you was just like cleaned up you
know listen I had to you a high and
tight type of dude high and tight high
and tight you know you gota you gota you
know like the Yankees you got to keep it
like the Yankees nice and clean this say
high and tight I'm done
anyway listen it was official man but
this product is dope it is so easy to
travel with so let's highly recommend
that lawn more 5.0 y'all make sure so
you travel with the Box no no we put
that I got the box for the show but this
is it right here and you know what I'm
saying it's officially you get the USB
you get the USB GAC going
on that's how you charge us yeah yo week
two week two how we looking all right so
mine again is the you know the bid
hedger right hey yo check it out unlike
Cog you know this comes with a little
travel joint
[Laughter]
so you ain't walking out like you ain't
out here with the box like
y but um yo so I caught myself cleaning
up before the show today y'all may see
my bed a little crooked on the
side y so I put my joint on I'm like
yeah let's go get it man let's get
outside but it's definitely what's up
this is definitely one of the best
Hedges that you know that the market can
bring you you know
um on the
side hit it Y and and it's really
different because I thought they was
going to give you the same trimor uh
just for the bid n this is actually a
larger more robust uh a little bit more
in control and way more powerful than
the lawn mower as far as you know cuz
the face cuz you know the hairs on your
face is a little bit more coarse a
little bit longer uh downstairs it
should not be this long yeah so you
should not have a larger trimmer but
this larger trimmer is definitely worth
it it aerodynamic you can see it like
you get little on
that very fail adct before we delve into
more Lord
at he's like I'm not talking yeah I'm
sorry I'm just having a hard time
talking it's it's been a good experience
you know uh I I definitely PE people
people like to bring I definitely grow
beer pretty fast yeah all are I heard
they need to hedge
that well you know I I'm definitely
appreciative over uh you know having the
tools to maintain my my my my
beardin uh but uh I I would I would I
would bet you Grace is way more
appreciated there you goly shout out to
Lady adct shout out to lady adct say to
lady adct but I will tell you this I am
in totally in agreement as we discussed
before you never want to be told to take
care of that region want to do it
yourself so for me as you can see I have
not shaved again right before the show
but I did use my products during the
course of the week and it is a again
it's a game changer because for me in
the middle of the week I don't have time
to get myself a full haircut and shave
and stuff like that so you take the you
take the the trimmer bring everything
down at least for a little bit and then
usually the plan is to to be shaved and
ready to go for the show on Sunday and
that never really happens but
these products are absolutely amazing so
thank you Lords for giving me your
impressions on the uh 5.0 Ultra package
so as we all know every man knows how
scary it is it can get when going for a
close shave below the waist that's why I
trust manscape for all of my sensitive
areas I'm lucky to be one of the first
to try the new lawn mower 5.0 Ultra and
to say it's a game changer is an
understatement as of course the Lords
have just let you know manscapes fifth
generation trimmer features two nextg
interchangeable skin safe blade heads a
standard trimmer blade for taking a
little off the top and a new foil blade
to go for that smooth finish wherever
your heart
desires no more wet shaving down there
count me in this bad boy also features
dual LED spotlights to provide contrast
on multiple skin tones so you can shed
some light on your darkest places light
our darkest hour let's do
that
hilarious we're talking three length
setting combs for all of your desired
lengths and oh did I mention this
trimmer is waterproof too taking it on
the go manscape has you covered this
puppy comes with a travel case and even
a travel lock feature to avoid any
accidental powering and or weird looks
in the airport yeah you don't want you
hear the buzzing sound in the airport
they're going to assume it's something
else this right here is on The Cutting
Edge of cutting pubes upgr your ball
trimmer and your life will follow so get
20% off and free shipping with the code
iron Lords manscape.com that's 20% off
plus free shipping with the code iron
Lords manscape.com your balls have been
through enough it's time to go Ultra
with manscaped salute another another
manscape joint in the books make sure
you go get that put the look in the
description right quick just make sure
you go hand that y handle my brother
came
through hey hey what came through my
brother came through oh we got that tuss
that's right we ain't got the sponsor we
can't show it we got the
show good thing we blurred that out God
is good God is
good if you're listening and you want to
know cuz we got history with
Tess so the real deal not
t what I do it's like it's like have you
ever been a point where you can't do a
podcast we got a thing for you we got a
thing for you Lord addict
representative that would be hilarious
all right we are all caught up will this
thing put me to sleep um nah sh it ain't
like that night well so you should rock
that oh you going to go to
bed he good right it ain't like the uh
night Quil Jo we all caught up we got a
couple of super we got a break Jeff here
Danny Danny passion official $2 Super
Chat Danny passion original is coming
alleway to his fire shout out to you
then we have hood hood ninji gaming and
what's the it doesn't tell me the whole
thing it says Hood ninja gaming and
something entertainment I'm assuming uh
$5 Super Chat the person you can't find
anymore is Betty she's stranded in the
in the Helen H hen system make sure you
have a ship part I'm on day 15 wow
that's a lot of time in
game hel system um then we have Lord
Metroid $2 Super Chat King in the
bathroom drops the trimmer
[Laughter]
ah then we have Vic the doing that then
we have Vic the mother effing click5
Super Chat clean up guys don't have your
girl sneezing on your meat from them
long hair no you got to put you on
timeout
sir no doubt we good shout out yeah but
it's funny cuz my my screen is Frozen on
because two heads are better than
one biggest thing I want to apologize
that I'm sorry you too messing up for
you guys today I see some of you have an
issue some of you not ain't nothing we
can do man we changed the whole format
just to try to make it work no doubt and
then we got the legendary David Jaffrey
in the building we get a mic check from
you
sir well hello fellas how you doing
hello there we go what you doing over
here man look good what's going on how
we feeling how was I'm feeling great how
was the wedding the wedding was
fantastic you were talked about and
missed people wanted to see you and they
said we're going to go to San Francisco
no excuse next time I saw the pictures
though what wonderful pictures and they
both look so cool and so happy and it it
was pretty cool it was pretty cool cool
and uh Jean and um Dustin wanted to
laugh at you how you how you got them oh
good yeah yeah yeah yeah that was
awesome that was awesome salute to you
no doubt so we going to get into these
topics right quick so um actually
probably could use Jeffy on this one cuz
most of us have don't have a lot of game
time on this one so Alan win too I don't
know if got Jeff you got a chance to
play it we wanted to talk about it real
quick we hear the impressions are strong
so let's start with you I I don't have a
lot to say because I'm only I'm only
about an hour into it I'm still sort of
deep into Spider-Man um okay yes and I
took the time cuz I'm like everybody's
talking about Alan Wake and I knew we
would be talking about today so you know
what I have played so far um you know
it's great it's very it's you know it's
a nice opening I will say the opening
before you actually get to the main
protagonist and stuff is like I I was
watching going that's that's probably if
I was like a 10 or 11 year old kid
that's a scary as crud
opening like you know okay that that'll
give some kids nightmares in a fun way
um it's real good and then you know
you're walking around and the I'm not
gonna you know you open the game you
know you're playing as this guy there's
some butt cheeks in this out there
there's not just butt cheeks but it's
like um I I don't know if they I don't
know if they modeled him off uh review
Tech USA or me but the point is
Yo Goodman I felt I felt seen I can tell
you
that you know but uh anyway no but I
mean you know and after that it it it
kind of is in a it's intro I'm
introducing you to a bunch of stuff and
it really feels to me like one of those
games that I may not even play right now
um because I know I'm I think I'm really
going to like it a lot maybe more than
that but I want to kind of be in the
right head space and right now my head
space is all like I want to see what
happens with Spider-Man yep um and I
haven't finished it yet so NE but I'm
enjoying it it's really good and and the
performances are good and the graphics
are great and you know there's nothing
bad to say about it yet and I'm excited
cuz people say is great no doubt Lord
adct our resident horror game player how
we feel
about Dr
that he dropped I say I dropped it I
didn't even start
start yeah I'm good on all that you
don't like the horror games I saw I saw
home girl walking on two hands I'm
good oh so what you to do with the
horror movie when they when the house
tell you get out you listen and you in
the house see I'm the kind of when I
look at I'm the kind of dude that I look
at I look up reviews before I go
anywhere you know I go to a B&B and I
sitting there and they're like oh this
place has been haunted oh I'm not going
there like it's like you know I'm the
kind of person I used to I used to own a
house and I sold it because it was
haunted yes he did he
did I've SE I've seen enough movies to
where I know where this is heading if at
this point after as many movies as and
stuff has been made if you get yourself
caught up in a situation like that it's
your fault adct was with us with high
guys right yes oh yeah
he so I don't know how you did because I
didn't do well in that place because
first of all our Uber driver drove us
through a a cemetery to get get to the
place and then when we get to the place
it is the creepiest Resident Evil place
ever that's when we stopped doing
airbnbs High guys definitely stopped us
from doing airbn we walked outside and I
looked up you had to go through like an
Alleyway to get to the house like no we
good we good did you have to disclose
when you sold the house that you thought
it was haunted or you only have to
disclose it someone was murdered in it
cuz that's a real thing if somebody get
murdered in your house you have to tell
people we had we we had people that
passed away in it but they were never
murdered so we have to disclose
anything man I would have bought that
house
I I would love I if I was in the market
for a house again I would totally go
those realtors that sells haunted houses
I would love that I would love it I
think the reason it messed with me is
because when I I remember being like 12
13 and I remember being in that house
and I was looking straight at a mirror
and I saw a a cette just just a figure
and I thought it was my mom and I turned
around and there's no one there oh hell
no and then there was a couple times I
remember one time being in the room
beside the kitchen and I was laying down
on the bed and I just heard on your
stomach you was on your stomach wow I
heard I heard this I heard this this
sounded something straight out of the a
grudge and and I remember thinking maybe
it's in my head maybe I'm hearing this
but the dog I had a dog beside me his
ears popped up so he heard it too I was
like yeah I'm out left like I didn't
stay there like I maybe there was just a
noise in the garage I mean do you get do
you leave whenever you hear noise in any
room you're not in you know ja was so
bad it's like you're at a restaurant and
there's a noise in the kitchen and you
run out and it's like yeah they're
cooking your food ex it was it was so
bad yeah it was so bad yeah that I've
had family members claim that they the
only time they've ever had nightmares
was in that house I've had people that
said they they have slept over there and
literally had a nightmare of of someone
coming there and killing everyone so so
you so as soon as you got old enough you
just got rid of it no no it didn't even
get that far I I got to the point I
refused to live in it my mom had to sell
it oh y okay okay listen listen not to
take us off the rails but but we going
off the rails with this yeah we go all
right so so I'm in the house none of us
played the game and yeah so we talking
about this horror random horror stories
inste out we all right so so listen
listen I'm getting ready by the house
that I'm in right now right this is the
house that I'm in so we're we're we're
going here and we're going through all
the rooms and the Real showing us all
the rooms so we go upstairs to the attic
and the attic is a fully uh furnished
bedroom right with Walkin closets nice
stuff right but then there's this one
little creepy door right there one
little creepy door there a little creepy
closet and you had a creepy door I had a
creepy house you see but but list but
listen attic so so you open this little
creepy door and it leads to the the the
storage part part of the attic right
it's
unfurnished it has a little light that
you click on inside and you look in
there you like m that's not a thing for
me right you that's the feeling that you
get in your heart this is that's like
something n this is not cool but it was
nothing in there right so I I looked I
looked inside cool in my head when we
were leaving I said yeah we ain't going
to get this place cool close the door on
the creepy closet we're walking all down
the steps I'm the last one I'm bringing
up the rear as we're coming down the
steps the creepy Closet
open come
back I look my heart said hell no I said
and as I'm walking I said yes this is
the house we're going to get right and I
said that right so okay going down we
get the house we get the house I'm like
oh everything went smooth pay for the
house everything damn it all right so uh
the wife ex-wife is at the the the at
work the kids is at school I'm sitting
in the middle of the living room mhm
watching TV and I hear Boom Boom like
running down the steps like like Steps
like something running down the steps
yeah he's here we got him we got him now
so there's nobody in the house but me
and I'm looking at the TV and I sit at
the edge and I look at the steps and I
I'm frozen in fear terrified absolutely
terrified the hairs is running up my
back the hairs on my head the Little
Peach fuz on my head is standing up my
beard is doing whatever it's doing and
I'm looking at the steps and then
because there's a moment of fight and
flight right and in my heart I said to
the ghost with all the conviction in my
heart dude I just got this mortgage we
in this
together man that's why I don't be
playing like horr because I lived in a
horror game for years why do I want to
play any of so the end the end part of
that is I have to get a
dog the word off the evil spirits yes
yes I said I said I said cuz they said
when you scared get a dog
right so I said I said my big behind got
to get a dog
that the debut of Coco Chanel Johnson
that was the debut of that was the debut
of Sir Benjamin Johnson and yo I'm not
going to lie that's how I came to get a
door cuz kaga tell you I didn't have any
animals except for um shorty do W when I
was growing up and other than that it
was no animals and then this love for
dogs came out of nowhere and I know
these dudes is like yo what's going on
so it was born out of
fear the dog has the dog sensed anything
or seen anything
n no but they they they have my attitude
and um I just got I got more comfortable
with the house I I like I I really told
the house like yo listen high five is
the ghost the way downstairs yo yo for
real like cuz you know I told the ghost
I said listen listen listen everything
yo I'm got it I'm broke ghost and this
is where we at with this I I don't have
enough to sell this place we in This
Together say I'mma love this place and I
hope you love me protect me like let's
keep everything that's not supposed to
be in here out let's do this together
ghost so the ghost has is a mod for the
show
right he probably is Yo probably
is y' messy getting back to Alan Wake
yes so that was my Alan Wake experience
so that was your Alan Wake experience uh
s you're one of the few that played it
apologies cuz this is my topic but lady
s was not having it yesterday she's like
no no gaming for you today I got you we
all we all suck at this topic so um yeah
so I I installed it and I the time that
I did spend with it was mostly dealing
with the settings on the PC right
because uh this yeah I'm G tell you this
right now this game in some ways if
you're if you're messing with ra tracing
this game is a new crisis it's like can
you run Allen way too is really what it
is you had a hard time running on on
rpcs they have with path tracing on and
all the bells and whistles yeah bro oh
so it's a beast this is this the new
crisis now it has to be a beast to be
having issues for all for suce yeah now
this is it if you turn off raid tracing
completely and just use rasterized uh
shadows and stuff like that 4K running
at like over 60 FPS no problem looking
beautiful but you you have to turn off
the rage tracing which is supposed to be
the big sort of wow moment for this uh
for this game so I I played a little bit
of that to jaffrey's point I did go into
the uh a little bit of the beginning
that that very first part that nightmare
inducing and that that was one of the
things that my wife because my wife
happened to be there when I I started it
that part she's like what the hell are
you playing she was she like okay we're
going to the bedroom this is getting me
Randy she like you're watching model
this after
you tell you what messy messy she was
disgusted she's like why am I seeing
this man's and it was it the water was
glistening on his body it was it was
beautiful technically but it was
horrific so yeah that that that kind of
messed up the whole thing and I couldn't
play anymore um so what I have played
though the most interesting stuff that
I've heard right because I I didn't look
at too many too much in the way of
reviews or anything like that um just
kind of overviews and a lot of people
what they're saying is like this feels
like the come comination of all of their
games like and in some ways they're
magnet they're magnumopus to this point
because all the stuff that they learned
kind of like from Quantum break and the
storytelling there where it's like okay
don't go don't go full uh you know
episodic sitcom but do intersperse it
with gamepl the stuff that they learn
from control in terms of giving you a
little bit more of an not an open world
feeling but kind of a linear wide feel
where you have to kind of look for story
within the game play and stuff like that
as opposed to and I know adct doesn't
like this but having you know to read a
whole bunch of documents and stuff and
and finding the stuff in the world so
it's kind of them figuring out the
middle ground to that stuff and
implementing it all in this game so I'm
excited to see if that is the case one
of the coolest things that I did see I
don't know if you got to this point yet
Jeff but I think you did when she first
goes to her mind place the Mind place is
cool because it reminds me of um I don't
know if any of you guys ever saw the
Hannibal TV show right I I've I've
always
of Silence of the Lambs Manhunter
Hannibal whatever so the Hannibal TV
show with mods mson is Hannibal um it
goes into the story of Will Graham that
was the first person that that was the
person who actually caught Hannibal
Lector in the books and Will Graham is
is is an sort of like an he's an FBI
agent who has this ability and and
Hannibal himself calls him like an Ider
Ider so somebody who can be who can be
sympathetic to what the murderer is
doing and place themselves in there
sort of in their of shoes in their
emotional state to sort of figure things
out and that's how will would sort of
figure things out and and see what the
and come up you know with what the
killer was going to be able to do next
um so it was interesting that they did
that kind of there because I Hannibal
that show is amazing to me so to see
that sort of thing sort of play out
where she sort of disappears into this
place where she's basically processed
all the information that she's gotten
from any given sort of uh case case or
or clues of a murder or whatever and
it's in within this place where she's
able to put all that stuff together and
figure out what's going on so to see
that sort of brought to life in a way
that I saw in that show uh was pretty
cool um I I I I will say the two things
about that the Mind place or whatever
she calls it
uh first off I mean I'm barely into the
game so this isn't spoilers I'm just
guessing I have to assume they're going
to do something narratively with that
because it's so prevalent whether it's
like the bad guy traps her in there or
it catches on fire or it starts to
change the other thing that's really
cool about it is that there's different
parts it's like you can do the workbench
and work on your weapon you can do the
crime stuff you can do a couple other
things and you're in this cabin but the
different places are all over the room
and it's just a minor thing but it's
just a nice quality of life thing where
wherever you're looking if you hit X it
just goes there you don't have to
actually walk your character to the wall
or walk walk your character to the
workbench you can you know but you were
mentioning like Hannibal and like you
red dragon's a great book about that was
the you know but this had so far this
has a very uh Season One True Detective
feel uh as well which if you haven't
seen that it's amazing but it's got that
kind of flavor to it and I think they do
a really good job at it so I'm digging
it I I here's the question it is one of
the best reviewed games of the year
anticipated Game of the Year beautiful
game and all of them us have either not
even had a chance to play it yet yeah or
uh uh we've only barely scratched the
surface and so in a lot of ways it's
like yes that says good things about
2023 in terms of the amount of just
great content facts I wonder if this is
going to be one of the the the sort of
uh snubs no not snubs but like
commercial flops in terms of Yep this
was the one that should have moved when
they were playing the game of chicken
you know and I'm not saying that's the
case we'll see what the and it did move
but it only moved a week yeah it it
shouldn't moved further because you
brought up Spider-Man that you're
playing I did the same thing I said let
me uh do all I can as Spider-Man get
past the story so I can move on to the
other games that I'm playing like you
know Dead Space remake uh Allan Wake to
and you know we talked about it because
I wanted to play the game and talk about
it on today's show I'm so entrenched in
Spider-Man that I wasn't able to be
pulled away from it even with you know
the stuff that's going on over there
it's just the fact of the matter is some
of these games could have move to the
following year at least you know or in
December I don't know why people don't
release in December I can tell you if
you're interested in a little inside
baseball on a w [__] yeah please when it
did um a guy here's what he said he
didn't give me much he said um I can
tell you precisely why they released it
in this window meaning Allan Wake this
was the last Pro I'm not going to tell
you how how he knows um
he says it's not a big deal to be honest
more of a decision based on investor
interest and other projects in the
pipeline and that maybe that may be the
case I'm sure it is because this guy
would know but at the same time it's
like yeah but you guys have this amazing
game yeah people might miss it you know
and that's a tragedy man but I mean
they'll maybe they'll eventually come
back to it but they those guys have
never you know been the number one game
of the year or anything even control
it's just they I don't know if it's the
games they make which are Wonder ful but
a little niche or they just kind of
don't have a good release plan who knows
but I mean do you guys remember uh what
day the original shift and what game
shift alongside it Allan Wake one Allan
Wake one shift on the same day as a as a
little game called Red Dead Redemption
oh oh wow wow yeah yeah but you know was
crazy it it still kind of got its shine
though it didn't obviously Red Dead took
some we
definitely because it was Rockstar doing
a rockstar s game W with Cowboys a lot
of people including myself was like I
don't want to play this Cowboy game I
don't care who made it but you can't you
can't blame Allan Wake for launching now
though because it launched right before
Halloween this is the month that it
should launch it should launch yeah
right and Spider-Man should have
launched in September but you know they
moved from Starfield and I think
in unconfirmed K new site hey you know
you know my my sources right here news
King News Network King News
Network it's the ghost of
ofana is haunting your
house so now I I I think they they had
the the thought process was right you
know spooky time spooky game we be the
best spooky game this month and I think
you know Spider-Man probably blindsided
I'm be honest with you a few weeks out
could have would have helped them
immensely I think think just a few more
weeks closer to Thanksgiving or whatever
but yeah I I agree I think they probably
should have come out in January February
frankly but I mean if you I I think
you're absolutely right when it comes to
movies and TV spooky stuff but games
have sort of historically shown if you
look at like when Resident Evil uh was
Village the last one what was the last
big Resident Evil they put out Village
yeah Village remake to was was was early
in the year yeah yeah these that hasn't
really borne the same kind of fruit like
hey let's release Five Nights at
Freddy's and it's $80 million in the
first three days you know because it's a
movie and Halloween so I I think
honestly they should have just said look
this this is this is a not good place to
be uh but then again if you guys
remember when they put control out I
think they finance these things on their
own and I think they uh the budgets are
not comparable to these $150 million
budgets when they put control out once
it sold through 2 million copies they
kind of took out an ad or some kind of
YouTube thing or whatever and it's like
wow two million and Square Enix would
have been like you know committing what
it's called sepu or
something but but for these guys because
their budgets maybe are smaller they
don't have these kind of investor I
don't know but they were like hey two
million's a lot so maybe for them
they'll do fine but in Our Minds when we
see a game only do two million that's of
that quality it's like yeah yeah you
should have been should have been the
thing so I think this this the budget on
this was 50 million because I
million something like that so yeah this
so control was about 30 30 million euros
and so I believe this one's supposed to
be somewhere in in the range of like 50
million EUR something like that W that's
good I jump out she get a chance to to
play yet but uh obviously for what both
of you saying jaffy saying shout out to
my man um I bontis he we were talking
about he was talking about on last word
because he's reviewing it and he Raves
about the sound quality and and just
like the atmospheric level of the game
he he and he's horror guy so he's just
like look he's like or whoever like I
I'm telling you man you have to play
this game he uh Rand already has it as a
game of the year nominee like
he he exactly so this is a lot of hype
and then remember 13 years I guess from
the first one and you know the remedy
quality you know so I'm hearing great
things I will get to it it's just like
jaff said it's just such a crazy year
and to try to fit everything and I don't
want to interrupt Spider-Man I don't
want to interrupt you know what I've
been doing with Starfield the new game
plus it's just so much stuff right now
but yeah salute to them cuz I'm hearing
great things I am hearing um like you
said all um graphically it's a it's a
Powerhouse and then um I am hearing the
Xbox performance is really good with uh
like like rna2 and mes shaders and stuff
like that they're implementing some new
technologies there and uh I know we'll
talk about the partner showcase but it
was interesting to see that see it at
the partner showcase on the same week
and I'm like it's coming out yeah I
that's interesting y don't really got
the marketing and that's an epic publish
game I thought it was I to me I look at
like might tried to mend fences a little
bit that's how I looked at it but I know
I could bring let's bring them home but
I I could be looking into it more into
it cuz I know from what I've heard you
know in the relationship before wasn't
the best so you know we'll see what it
is but that's it's still in the
acquisition season so so budget budget
budget is70 million EUR with 50 being
development and 20 spent on marketing
yeah well again I hope my my last point
is I hope that it does get the
recognition you know it deserves I do I
do feel for the game of the year now
committee cuzz this year is crazy like
we really can't go hard on them this
year cuz something's going to get
slummed if if they stick to the format
of six games and Allan Wake impresses
that way I think it's like a 88
Metacritic right now it's 89 right now
and 90 open critic yeah it's it's up
there again I I empathize with anyone
trying to nominate Game of the Year this
year it's crazy yeah I know with
Spider-Man
Starfield uh you know tears of the
Kingdom you know you know those those
three you know then y talk about this
bolders gay
thing B gay outside even even UFC they
say this is the best UFC game ever come
no no listen if Forza can't get
nominated UFC don't have man but that's
all I got let's move sorry I'm just
really fascinated by this because $50
million $50 million American dollars or
whatever that translates to and you've
got a game that's at an 88 and that if
they would have positioned it maybe a
little better uh you know it could have
sold a lot more and I'm just wondering
how they're able to make their you know
that game visually stands toe-to-toe
with other games and it's like okay so
where are they what is their secret
sauce that lets them make a game for $50
million that is able to be still
seriously considered triaa yeah yeah
know it's crazy so they they're fully
digital now right they're not really
selling physical copies at all of it it
is $60 it's not a $70 game $60 on
console and $50 on on PC
SE epic EP done steep it up they gonna
get their money man now it doesn't hurt
of course that the lead actor is also
the writer exactly he didn't have to pay
he didn't have to pay
himself do it I'll do it that's a fact
now salute to alwi back hearing good
things we will get to it let's move on
super chats we got some topics yeah we
got a couple chats topics we have a BT
Maverick 7 7 $10 Super Chat curious if
David jaffy thinks there is a
non-compete clause for Connie Boo's
contract even after being fired in case
uh if a certain company is recruiting
thank you guys for the great show you
could ask that now I was going to ask
you when you come I have I have I have
no idea how that works I mean I I know
that if you split from a company if
you're laid off and you want your
Severance or this or that or the other
it'll be like okay well you need to sign
this you know you can't talk about your
time here you can't talk about this or
that that or the other
um that's pretty common but when you get
fired I don't know if that or the
non-compete kcks in like I mean con
let's put it this way Connie started
working at Sony before I did and people
always ask me about my contract I'm like
I never had a contract I never you know
so I can't imagine you know unless
somewhere along the line they pulled her
into a room and said hey we need to get
you contract because there was never a
contract for me so when I left I mean I
I left on good terms but if I wanted to
I could have talked up I mean that's why
I talk now I don't have a you know
something saying I can't so but as for
going to another company
um probably I mean I don't I don't know
I I I really my answer is I don't know
it's an interesting question but given
that she was fired and not laid off and
given that we don't know if even if she
was fired um was there some kind of
package incentive like yeah you're fire
but if you want all this you got to do
this
you know and I I I just don't know but
it's it's a it's a good question yeah
good question salute what else we got
solv then we have David hot right $10
Super Chat very happy to see David jaffy
in the realm yes yeah he's back back in
business can I tell you something though
somebody in your chat said uh why is
jaffy here so that one counters that one
also shout out to the one dude out of
00 he didn't oh I see it even though he
didn't spend any money for it I do want
to give him an answer answer to his
question I'm here because your mom and I
finished
early bang bang seing Street G early
early continue There we have Daddy
passion official $5 Super Chat my friend
invited me and my wife to pray for her
at her house and the kitchen dishes were
making noise like if someone was
breaking them and no one was this you
know I'm not Oh see now now you bringing
stuff be there in a heartbeat I I mean
cuz I don't even oh so you're a ghost
hunter you like that stuff I think I
mean seriously I think I I'm not saying
I wouldn't be scared I'm like I'm you
know but I want to you know if there's
actual life after death and there are
real ghosts and I've never seen any
evidence success there are I'm like okay
yes I'm terrified because it's just so
weird but I'm want to talk to this
person it's like okay wait a minute
they're not talking jaffy those those
ones are the violent
ones it's not like the ghost was in the
kitchen saying hey I got a conf
I can talk I can talk anybody down from
a ledge if that ghost is mad I'll deal
with it I'm saying the fact that death
that life or Consciousness continues
after life I'm that's much more enticing
to me than being afraid of Oh no you're
a ghost I want to talk to that D
fascinated by the his curiosity his
curiosity killed the cat I feel you yo
Jeffy listen I want to say this right my
curiosity ain't that
deep you don't want to know what's going
on N no I get to that bridge when I get
out of jail free card cuz you got you
know Mike your ass to kill the cat yours
going to kill your dog so you
got got buffer y
messy with my dog what else got we got
Daddy passion official $2 CH almost
almost forgot she was messing with Ouija
see there you go there we go if you
preface that like hey I need you to pray
for me because I was doing dumb thing no
no you he opened the portal it would
have know why why
exactly what else we got moving on then
we had Hood nin jaichi gaming and
entertainment $5 Super Chat my bad I
misspelled it it's the the hinin hinin
system southeast of CCS KR YX salute to
the Lords from UAW oh salute much love
and we're CAU up get let's get into it
now this is the big one obviously we had
to uh get my mans David jaffy in on this
one and yeah we want to talk Connie Boo
and um obviously potential PlayStation
Studios um um changing some say turmoil
there's a lot obviously you know uh this
was per access but they gave proper
credit to Lord David jaffy on the
sourcing and uh Kylie Bo who started at
PlayStation in 97 before the platform
launch she started in in uh 87 88 wow
take it back not at PlayStation but at
Sony or 89 I think 89 salute salute
that's OG talk so yeah head of internal
game production no longer at the company
as first noted by uh David chaffy and um
yeah somebody Hall of Fame credentials
include production oversight of
PlayStation Classics ranging from siphon
filter ratcheting Clank to The Last of
Us Marvel Spider-Man says booth has not
commented and Sony has not clarified the
reason for her exit in a statement by
axios the PlayStation refs said Booth
helped Drive the success PlayStation
Studios is experiencing today and her
passion in fostering an environment
where A team's Creative Vision could
fully flourish has left a positive
impact on many game developers we're
thankful for Connie's numerous
contribution to the company and wish her
the best in future endeavors also the
article goes on to talk about other
internal things with Sony media M Min
molecule Studio making some little uh
big planet and dreams says it's laying
off some workers following significant
strategic changes so um yeah obviously
Jaffrey you know you had a lot of this
on on your YouTube channel you broke
this first um there was some specific
points that you made I want to kind of
list and then ask you kind of like in
question format if you're cool um so all
right the f one of the first things was
like Connie boo was not let go she not
retire she was fired so Lord jaffy why
is her firing opposed to like a layoff
or resignation significant and then
educate me who doesn't know why she's so
revered why you know so many people like
yourself internally speak up for her in
production like what's the history here
well again so I mean she hasn't said
anything so there's you know all I can
tell you is I have like four people
telling me what happened to at Sony and
two are out of Sony and they're all like
no she was fired um so the significance
of
it there's two things that are very
significant the first thing is if you
look at uh who she is and what she has
done I mean the Academy of interactive
Arts and Sciences two years ago put her
in the Hall of Fame this is not a woman
who's out to pasture and they're like
hey thanks for all the fish goodbye this
is a woman who literally less than a
month ago you know her crew put out
spider man 2o which is kind of the only
[__] freaking game that uh you know
that Sony had I mean MLB of course you
know work course of Sony's MLB but you
know that that's not like she's over
she's still totally plugged in doing
what she does her guys plugged in doing
what they do um so part of it is like
okay it's significant because this is
somebody who's making you guys a lot of
money and her leadership has been very
valuable over decades um she's not ready
to be done it's not you what I'm saying
it's not like okay your last four games
you're just out of the Zeitgeist now not
a big deal we love you but you know how
business works right that's not what was
happening um and the other reason it's
significant is it shines a light on
um the fact that because Sony I think uh
on Colin show he was talking about this
you know in in it given the the vacuum
that we are in when it comes to
information from Sony yeah we're all
left just to speculate and make crap up
and no one really knows but it it's one
of those it's it's one more pretty
significant brick especially after Jim
Ryan retiring and or maybe being pushed
out I don't know um that says okay what
is happening over there the factions
thing the Connie thing the gym thing um
and I don't think it's you know I I look
at it um and I have some information
that I you know I actually reached out
to to tillow at axus and I said I said
this guy reached out to me he's at Sony
he knows all kinds of stuff he he laid
it all bare he told me about Jim Ryan
and what he thinks Jim Ryan what
happened with Connie and you know but I
said it's one guy I said yeah he's at
Sony and he's he's a longtime Sony guy
but I don't he's like yeah you shouldn't
you know unless you got other sources
don't don't get into that but the the
point though is I think if people are
out there going Connie and then Jim ran
and then factions right uh and how much
control Bungie having and totillo or sh
L jasan sher's earlier reporting uh
about um the studios being unhappy with
games as a service at least some of them
I I I think it's a valid and the
information Source I'm talking about
tracks with this it's a valid thing to
go that that uh Foundation right now is
being shaken up and and and where they
come out the other side or what that
looks like um and whose vision is
running the day in terms of do we stay
with games as a service as at the level
we thought we were do we pivot a little
bit back you know that is why it's
significant because it's just one more
really big reason to go yeah they're
they're struggling to kind of sail into
the next uh uh sort of Epoch of the
games industry which they have dominated
for so long so I don't think it's a bad
thing I think in a lot of ways Xbox is
going through I was talking to somebody
earlier it's like
Xbox um I'm a big Phil Spencer fan I'm a
big game pass fan um but I've always
been very critical of their production
management when it comes to first party
and all that and I'm still I'm still
like Matt booty was promoted I'm sorry
what um but but but but and I don't know
the guy you know but whatever but it's
not the point the point is though is
that they you know it takes time to
learn even though these are trillion in
one case uh dollar companies it takes
time to learn how to do this and it
seems like Xbox has struggled for a
while and they're still struggling but
they're getting better I think to learn
how to become the kind of management
Studio that Sony was I think Sony now is
put into this position where as Shawn
Laden predicted five years ago four
years ago the things that they've kind
of made their uh Brilliance in which is
the single player cinematic all that
stuff just one it it's becoming harder
and harder to justify those budgets
because the profits aren't as much
because you know and there's not new
Gamers coming in and so they're having
to go okay well how do we
still you know rule this
industry and and take what we're great
at but we have to Pivot somewhere things
are changing so it it really is a uh
it's a fascinating and uh just you know
very interesting to me uh uh perspective
to stand back and watch all this from a
30,000 foot View and go you know where
these guys going to come out the other
end are they going to be able to figure
out how to sustain these big games come
out the other end pause
King pause on King continue continue J
you being messy
continue um so yeah I mean I I I think
it it it's quite interesting to me and
you know it does remind me speaking of
A's ghost but I saw a speak at GDC a
couple years back or 10 years back now
and he was talking about how in trouble
Nintendo was when they I think it was
like out of the GameCube era right
before the 3DS or the DS or whatever it
was and you know he he gave this now
very tropy but at the time none of us
had heard it uh analog he said you know
uh Coke and Pepsi used to battle like
crazy and it was one then it was Pepsi
then it was coke you know and then
suddenly something happened and Koke
just took over and Pepsi couldn't get a
break and so instead of continuing to
try to beat Coke um and swim in those
bloody red Waters he says they they
absolutely you know reinvented
themselves and they started bottling
water and they became now now Coke is
taking over that too but at the time
though you know their bottled water that
changed everything for them and and but
it's like but you're Pepsi you don't
make water it's like well we do
now you got rein yourself I think when
you hear him aana talking about how they
had to do that at Nintendo and go okay
we're not going to be able to compete uh
with the Sony's and and and whatever I
don't I guess Microsoft was out at the
time Microsoft's the world on Fidelity
on production value what are we good at
okay let's do the 3DS and the DS and
let's do the Wii and suddenly everything
changed for these guys so I I think
there's nothing to not you know it's a
company it doesn't have shame but
there's there's nothing to feel bad
about I mean this is how business gets
done this is how create you know I hope
there's a Visionary at Sony right now
maybe it's Scott roie maybe it's a new
person we've never heard of maybe it's
Herman Holst I don't I don't know maybe
it's dman who knows who is is going I I
got this I have this I see what this can
be um because I think they need that but
I think every company needs that you
know Apple used to have it he was an
[__] but you know jobs knew what he
knew and now they're just kind of awful
but anyway I want to I want to follow up
because the the the pivot part is the
part I really let say confused about but
I personally this is this is my take I
understand based on what you say like we
know Sony PlayStation I call them the
hashtag just one the triaa the Cinematic
narrative based Focus game high
graphical fideli that bit right and you
made a fantastic Point as far as the
revenue right and those maybe not being
able to generate what they're looking
for in this climate with games of the
service so in my opinion games of the
service is the correct pivot on some
level right the question is twofold one
if Jim Ryan's message was this right
internally from what you know you kind
of had said and then he either retires
or pushed out whatever it is right and
my thing is if that was the first
question is if that was Jim Ryan's
Vision why is kind of getting blamed for
it in a sense right and then the second
part is you know I tell me how you feel
about this story I have in reference to
Bungie being there overlooking the the
the the games of service right cuz I
look at it as okay we have a new adopted
child in the house and he go by his own
rule he don't have to go to bed at 10:00
he don't have he listens to his whole
thing and he gets to tell the other kids
what to do when it comes to their
projects right
so for me I all even though Bungie I
love them I a destiny fan I'm a Halo guy
I think they make nothing but the
greatest you know Shooters as far as
feeling Shooters but I can understand
resentment in the building if they're
telling and cancelling projects so again
the first thing games of service why
does it follow follow con two Bungie
potentially being problematic in the in
the in the family so to speak so on the
Connie thing I mean that's I I have one
person's answer that's the guy I can't
really get into but I asked him that I
said this doesn't make any sense the the
thing to to know I think is that when
people say it fell on Connie I don't
what we don't know is does that mean
that um oh no you know The Last of Us fa
I mean literally look at it this way the
last of his factions hired the guy who
figured out how to monetize fortnite and
not make a game that was pay for power
and it became the big biggest free to
playay game certainly from America ever
phenomenal um that guy left right that
guy left which means okay whatever their
plan was his plan was clearly Bungie
wasn't interested um and so what we
don't know is was it Jim Ryan you know
getting cozy cozy with Bungie and saying
you know now you
just that's what the Bungie people say
you know and and maybe Connie was there
going look man I've managed at some
level I mean Naughty Dogs doesn't really
need that oversight anymore but she's
been with them since crash right yeah um
it's like these guys are upset they're
pissed you got to you know I'm not
saying that happened but I'm saying that
it could it could mean when we say that
she was fired over that is she just
bashed heads with Jim Ryan going look
these guys are your bread and butter
you're going to literally tell Neil dman
who's probably about to get an Emy
nomination for Last of Us um that that
you know and by the way I don't think
Jim or Bungie would be wrong I mean it's
just like Xbox right now there are
things that you don't know what you
don't know right and if Bungie came in
and gave a valid criticism of their of
their stickiness of their game
stickiness was the word then you know I
mean one would like to think naughty dog
would say oh I hate that you're right
but you're right yep yep let us let us
go back we'll get back and that may be
what's happening right so it could be
that though that Connie pushed back on
Jim cuz there was this kind of turmoil
it also could be that um you know
everybody agreed when Jim Ryan started
to Pivot um to the games of the service
it's like oh that sucks but at least he
said there's a lot of money still being
spent on the single player stuff and uh
but everybody was like yeah they need
this this is where a lot you know if you
can get one or two of these big hits
what the hell is ready to burst clearly
I just got a question I got a question
the yeah that that part was really crazy
but um is Rome
burning here we go because I my my
thought process has always been Sony
won't be taken down from outside
interference they will Ex implode from
inside and I've always felt that great
Nations and great kingdoms has always
done it to the themselves so yeah no I
don't I don't think it's that dramatic I
don't because I think Sony is out of
necessity
responding to the changes in the market
and the frankly the generational changes
I mean kids today they're you know I'm
not saying they don't play console games
but they're playing they're on Discord
playing Discord games with their friends
and they're playing Roblox they're
playing fortnite you know they have a
very different perspective of what it
means to game um You Know Than People
Our Generation My Generation whatever
right and so I think Sony is right to go
okay we we got to get our hands around
this and and and make it work for us
without hurting all of our other stuff
that people love us for and and so I
don't think I don't remember anybody
when Jim Ryan came out and announced
this that they were like oh you're an
idiot every I think everybody was like
yeah yeah yeah and what has happened in
that time since though is we have just
seen a
just Blood Red Sea of really good games
that have come out that were games of
service that are no longer active yes
right and so I think there was an
assumption that not that it's easy
nothing's ever easy in video games but
it's like okay we can do this and they
probably can but I think maybe that kind
of the worm turned a little bit on
people's going [__] man we had to you
know put factions on Ice Andor cancel it
depending on who you ask um you know we
premiered Jade Raymond's game at the
Showcase and even though the game wasn't
shown nobody was like eh nobody really
cared uh hyenas just got cancelled
before it came out right um you know
apparently that game that's out the
finals this weekend in beta most people
are like yeah it's cool but I'm not
going to play it for more than you know
a day or two and they' they've already
moved on from a beta the the what was
the game that Square Enix just put out
on beta the oh was it the F was it foam
Stars foam Stars I mean I heard a lot of
people saying that was great at Jeff
Keeley show and I was excited for it you
know I'm 52 so I'm not their target
audience but I couldn't play it more
than you know around and I'm like yeah
this is not for me so it didn't no one's
talking about that like oh I can't wait
for foam stars to come back I'm not
hearing any of that um but what I am
hearing though on the flip side is you
know Ubisoft just released a bunch of
their uh uh quarterly reports and you
know uh Mirage did well which surprised
me the crew to or motorfest which is
awesome uh did uh did well but they said
their biggest money maker or their
biggest Financial surprise was Rainbow
Six Siege is still delivering yeah it's
a beast for those guys right Beast right
so I I don't think it's right to say
going games as a service for Sony is
stupid I think it's dumb I think it's
you know MLB makes the money as a semi
games the service right first party
Studio but what we don't know with
Connie is was she protecting the team
was she protecting the vision and Jim
wanted to Pivot there's also by the
way there's a very let's just say this
without giving away any of the details
there is a narrative that I've that's
been shared with me that it's not even
that it's not even
that logical okay that some of the
people in The Narrative whether you're
talking Jim or Connie or Shan leaden or
Herman Holz I'm not going to get into
the specifics but let's just say the
narrative there's a narrative that exist
that say some of those people
aren't or are pretty [__] Petty um
and there may be a narrative
regarding you know I'm gonna burn some
stuff down before I go I didn't say that
okay well listen okay you know what okay
so you didn't say but I did right so the
thing is because it doesn't make any
sense and I'm not saying that's true I'm
I yeah no I heard some something similar
right the thing is
Jim is gone in next school period at the
end like like I predicted anyway um but
her
leaving now like getting fired now if
there's a conflict of in interest
between the two or teams
whatever and he's a forgone conclusion
it just seems uh like Petty let me
remove this and not only that K not to
interrupt you aren't we hearing the team
in her team in conjunction with her I
don't know if the team walked out this
was the thing that's the key distin weal
we're all speculating but yeah from what
I heard and and and you you know way
more than me what I heard was I thought
it was a walk out right so I didn't hear
the rest of the information and then I
got the some of the rest of the
information and I'm pretty probably
getting the second hand from you um not
knowing that is is indirect the
individuals that's sharing the
information um that it was a walk out
but I didn't know if it was her but then
I'm hearing that she got fired so I
don't know if the team walked out after
she got fired she doesn't have a
development team as far as I know but
she had like producers right I don't
know if Brady hunt was still with her
who's been long time Insomniac third
part first-party producer with Insomniac
much loved fella you know probably on
track get a nominee or ushered into
Academy active Arts and Sciences you
know all that I mean you know her team
was awesome when you talk about what
Microsoft doesn't have in production
management right um for first and second
party her whole team was awesome now I
did ask that and and what they said was
um there's a few people left and we know
uh what's her name Angie smithz or
smithz from right it sounds like that
and then I guess they're going to split
some of her I saw somebody saying that
like roie was going to take over some of
her teams or some of her external like
maybe he would oversee Insomniac and
somebody else would oversee this
um but the point being though is is her
team I did hear that uh a number of them
were also out when she was out now
whether they were fired or they walked
because they were protesting I have no
idea see and again you know I give it
back to you King I interrupted you no no
no no it's it's fine because he he
answered the question I just felt that
it was it was just weird in the sense
that this individual is definitely gone
like he's definitely put out information
that I'm out of I'm retiring regardless
to what if he was fired or whatever and
he had to sign the paperwork saying you
know I'm out of but why is she tied to
this rock that that's what that's my
thing King cuz my thing is it all again
regardless if it was a walk out or they
were all fired to me that represents
culture right that represents obviously
she's revered she she gets things done
like the vibe I'm getting jaffy is like
this is the finisher this is the person
not only who spawns great ideas at some
of their greatest franchises but also
gets things across the Finish Line I
guess from a production she is a in the
best way possible a
beast you do not want her as an enemy
let's put it that way she plays the game
well she plays the game so the closest
equivalent I could say on the Xbox side
back in the day was be like Ferguson
right he was revered for like y he gets
it done we had Cliffy be on he was like
look no one I will never say nothing bad
about that man that man got things done
and got would go back to Microsoft I I I
mean he is kind of a now I wish they
would go to him and say dude you need to
run development I'm with you I'm with
you he I said regardless of whatever
happens to ABK I hope they retain him
and he I'm I'm totally with you there
but back on point with this so it's like
I guess when I hear you talk and I watch
your video and first of all credit to
you because you you you got a lot of
arrows thrown your way a lot of people
was hating and saying Oh but you doom
and glooming and it's not that bad and
you know jaffy sourcers and then you get
Vindicated but the key thing that you
said to me that resonated was like said
look this is a sad day you know at
PlayStation based on the history and
based on what she's done and based on
the team so again to what king is
talking about if this is the case and
she's like the soul in a sense like this
before PlayStation started right so if
that's the case it's like again we don't
know if she was in conjunction with Jack
with uh Ryan's Vision or not but it for
her to take the fall for this seems
strange it it just it just feels it
doesn't feel right just don't that we
just don't have like there's there's
scenarios like it could have been you
know it was uh and this is not like
Connie but you know like I said the
woman's been around she's done this
stuff and maybe she's just like okay
enough you know maybe she just went to
Jim Ryan and said you know you're an
idiot you know I don't I don't know how
insubordinate it was if it was at all
but it could have been literally a case
for firing because he was just
disrespecting all these people that had
basically without them he would have no
job right or she could have agreed and
they both got thrown under the bus
together if he indeed got thrown or it
ALS I mean you know I know and I'm sure
you guys have heard too that Sony is
doing a lot of serious belt tightening
right now yes yeah all their Studios and
it could have been as simple but they
would never say this as going you just
put Spider-man out uh you're in line to
get a huge bonus when when the monies
come in and your salary you know is
probably you know deep deep into the the
six figures um we probably can't afford
an executive like you especially now
that Naughty Dog pretty much runs itself
Insomniac pretty much runs itself I mean
I'm not taking away from what Grady does
you know but I'm saying that it's not
like it was maybe in the past and this
is me making stuff up I'm saying we all
speculated there's a lot of places you
could go with why they said goodbye but
what I do hear though is there's some
pettiness at play and what I can say
because people have said it before and
it's been discussed before and so I'm
not giving away anything I wouldn't want
to do that is you know there's been a
lot of speculation about how Shawn
leaden got yeah and you know and and and
the more I hear the more that you know
at first I heard it about Alan Becker
and I got it direct that he's like yeah
I heard that they they called like on I
don't know what day it was a Tuesday and
said your last day is Friday wow and
that was it that was it this is the guy
who was the first employee facts and had
done you would have no Twisted medal no
God of War probably I don't know you
know there's a lot of games he ushered
in uh he was there when bloodborne in
Japan you know I'm not I'm not saying he
wasn't ready to go but the that was the
first thing like Jesus that's not just
good Cutthroat business like you know
you got to be Cutthroat that's mean yeah
that's a squat you out the
building no that was that was that was
that was Allan oh was Allan okay sorry
sorry yeah
I'm get confused
apparently this is becoming more clear
by a number of people and not like I
said I'm not giving this one source um
that it was really offensive I mean it
it was like you're you know they did him
very very dirty getting him out of there
and so you know but it's like what how
can you s you go jum like I just I
struggle with Legends being treated this
way may again I'm outside looking I
don't burning get it but Sol like do you
guys see what I'm saying see though like
is that just wild disrespect but it's
not just the disrespect it's the it's
you're right but it's the it's the it's
the ability to maneuver politically well
enough that you can convince the powers
that be to give you a position that
clearly someone else has proven oh we
play they know and what they know how to
doow I think was a much better executive
than Jim Ryan in my opinion I don't know
I can't have the numbers but and people
say well look what Jim Ryan did with PS5
I'm like yeah but that's built off the
built off the old but we got we gotta
give him we got to give him Europe
though I got to defend Jim on Europe
with their growth there but I feel what
you're saying at all I'm just saying
that that Sean it wasn't like Shawn was
like eh of course oh that's yeah yeah I
mean he he still had and still has a lot
to offer and so the idea in my opinion
that he was sort of the more I hear the
more I hear he was treated so just like
yeah wow it's too it's trash Tuesday so
you're trash you're out um I'm just like
are you out of your mind you know this
you know so let's just say this if
there's a pettiness going on
um you know I'm glad that it may not be
going on for too much longer um yeah so
I need to jump in and I got I got
something for king after this I want you
I got you I want need your thoughts on
all this um H I just think at the end of
the day everything is money everything
is money and when you talk about the
disrespect to these Legends um we've
seen it before you know Konami gets fed
up with coima we don't really care what
you've done we don't care what you've
done for us like it's you're gone and
when you know the powers that be are
more focused on a different direction
and you clash with that direction in any
way shape or form it feel like you're
going to be on board with it or you're
going to use whatever you know whatever
clout you have internally at that point
to try to set up roadblocks to that
stuff happening they're gonna get you
out of there and if it has to be and and
I and I think in a lot of ways you know
maybe they gave her maybe they gave her
the opportunity to walk out and say hey
walk away and do it on your terms and
everything's going to be nice and
beautiful or if you refuse and you want
to die on that Hill cool we appreciate
that we're going to walk you out of
building and that's just the way it is
and it and it and that's just business
when when cash rules everything it
doesn't matter what you've done for them
it's what it matters what you've done
lately for them I I'm sorry please
finish please finish and the and we as
fans may see that as a disrespect be
because of what they've done to that
point to that company they're an
employee and again they're more than
willing to give them their flowers if
they go out on the terms that they
dictate for them if they don't want to
do that they're going to walk you out
like a criminal or whatever and going to
make sure and that's just the nature of
it so for me go ahead sorry I mean just
speculating again speculating completely
as to what might have happened it really
does feel like you know to jaffrey's
point she was not on board with what was
happening at least to the extent to
which it was happening right it's one
thing to say hey we need to start
dipping our toes into this in order to
also to another thing to tell every
first party Studio you better make one
of them
make these guys I didn't say that happen
I don't know if that's what happened but
that's another thing that we that we're
sort of we're assuming might have
happened is that this this you're
telling the teams that are known for
doing a certain thing extremely well at
the top at the top of the game in the
industry you're telling them to Pivot to
something else because we have to make
this you know extra amount of money and
then at the same time he also did the
right thing by bringing in teams and
bringing in people that know how to do
that and and working on that as well so
it at it seems like at some point that
pivot went extremely in One Direction
meaning more of like hey everything's
going to have some sort of game of
service sort of uh uh application to it
and everything that we put out H is
going to be somewhat in this realm
whether we still put out our you know
our single player you know 15 hour
narrative games um there's going to be
some component to it and maybe that's
something that she wasn't on board with
if you look at her history she's only
really worked on single player stuff
right cuz that that's been their get she
did so Cal she did so she did that okay
so she did okay take the back so she was
part of that now going back to that
Socom mag those are maybe mag is is a
bigger thing but those are very it's
different when it's a multiplayer game
service gam service there's a difference
yeah right and and I think we've talked
about this the fact that the pivot was
correct we've always felt it was a
little late to the party right and when
you're late to the part and you've
already seen so many other great games
just fall to the Wayside simply because
people don't have the bandwidth for
them you're you're thinking that we're
going to drop 10 or 15 of these the hope
that one or two of them hits and allows
us to continue to make money hand over
fist off of them in a world where you
know people's bandwidth is going to a
fortnite a war zone or is going to a
Whatchamacallit a a Siege or something
like that you have to now create another
Niche for that thing within your and
again an ecosystem that you have not
clarified that you were going to expand
upon so now you're creating a niche
within a niche within a closed within a
Walled Garden not saying that you're
going to go to the PC right so if if
that isn't something because to me if
you're doing that that's something that
we should know about already bewhere
right so if that is the case and you're
saying oh we're going to do this within
this closed PlayStation ecosystem and
I'm Booth I'm like okay now the choices
that you're making whether I agree with
them or not you're not even making sound
business decisions around around it
right and expanding the people that we
that we reach with these games doesn't
make a whole lot of sense that again
speculation I just kind of feel like
they were butting heads completely on
ideologies and it was time to go and
again it just kind of feels like her
thinking is we can do multiplayer right
we can do that but it's and and my point
when I talked about uh you know why does
why does factions have to be this huge
thing well I understand because they
they they separated it out as part it's
not it's not a part of of The Last of Us
Part Two anymore it's this own game I
understand that it has to be something
bigger I understand that you have to
make it into something that has that
stickiness that you have people coming
back to because of the amount of money
invested into it I get that um and I
just think for it it was it was going
too far in that direction and that's not
something she was on board for and the
it it just really feels like now the
scary part about that right when you
look at PlayStation and what people
expect of
PlayStation um obviously I would think
it's it's ridiculously stupid to to
Pivot completely away from them games
and hey we're not giving you these type
of games anymore you see the success of
a Spider-Man people's excitement for a
wolverine people's excitement for a
ghost of sushi sequel stuff like that
and and the next Last of Us so those
things are still going to be there but I
just think I think the Caden of those
games is going to be stretched out even
more these games may take you know and
jaffy I'm interested unless Herman Holz
has a plan where he says look wait a
minute this is ridiculous Allan Wake
just shipped for 50 million yeah it took
him a couple of years to make yep it's
it's a game of the year Contender for a
lot of
people we we can still make the kind of
games we're beloved for but we got to
figure out that's our pivot right maybe
that's what I mean who knows if I was
Herman Hol I'd be going what what what
are they doing there at remedy that we
should try that's Len point I like hey
we can we have to figure out how to be
able to make these games for less money
because the budgets are are the budgets
are out of control the amount of time
we're spending making them is out of
control right so how do we do that and
then to your point exactly remedy Allan
Wake proper went into production
whatever 4 five years ago although it's
been an idea in the making for the past
13 years but it is something that you
have to look at say hey look at this
level of quality so maybe we don't make
Ragnarok a 35-hour single player game
narrative game we make it a 20 hour game
right um and maybe we have Wolverine
taking place in the same universe as
Spider-Man as they announced they've
confirmed they've conf because maybe we
have a third of the game set in New York
that we already have built um and we'll
add stuff and we'll we'll make it feel
fresh but we're not going to reinvent
the wheel Insomniac it out of all the
studio
seems to know the formula for going
we're going to reinvent the wheel as
much as we can but we're also going to
ship on time and we're not going to kill
our teams and so there is something to
be said for that you know trauma that's
occurring in the industry right now
around single player AAA and going what
may emerge from that is someone cracks
the nut and says we can still make
viable great single player big games
we've just kind of gone a little crazy
with these like like you said
70 hour games and all that stuff I I
think this blo all the way around and I
think that the what's going to happen is
right it this is going to be a very very
bumpy ride because when we talk about
bloat people gonna lose their jobs if if
they come to the correct decision is how
do we figure out how to debloat this
thing and make quality games within a
reasonable amount of time with
reasonable budgets at the end of the day
that means people lose their job it's
going to happen I want to ask go ahead
go ahead yeah I got to ask been patient
um you know me and you
we we've been through all the
PlayStation errors right me and you you
know you were the first I never forget
that you know that gray system don't
forget about me I mean you were there
too I love you I love you but you got to
say king is my source cuz like I was
broke so he gets the Imports right and
I'm like I'm mooching I'm just going to
keep it real I'm mooching I'm young Co I
don't got money we mooching he brings
Japanese PlayStation we like oh my God
this is the most amazing thing I see b n
Co racer tack it on the system 11 board
I'm Blown Away jumping flash all these
crazy GES battle arena CH I'm hooked I'm
like so all day let's go they killed
Jeep
cast like whatever right so my thing is
to me it's like what we known them for
and then we according to jaffy like
she's part of this like she's the
essence of this right and and continues
on with a lot of their their biggest
games so I I look at that as like
culture what defines you right and then
I remember K you remember like PS3 came
out right and then was a little bit of a
what you say a let say culture change
but Attitude Change you know hey we got
get job kji was goinging little humorous
right come off thei was swinging for the
fences box he was swinging for the
fences and the goal post is yeah yeah he
was tearing it up he you have two jobs K
this facts for the George foran Grill
one but listen conversations has been
told for to have the same thing you know
shout out to Todd Howard let's go so my
question kick is like this maybe I'm
overreacting I don't want to get doom
and groom but it's like these are people
who made the culture of who you are
right this is the essence of why you're
successful tell truth is this part of
like I don't want to say like the
Arrogant heel turn again like are we are
we going because we're selling so well
they're not gonna get off of this one
but by but here's the KY in defense
though they are selling so well so you
could be sitting there and look like but
I'm saying forget I know your theory
about the SC but let's get all I'm say
it is the brass TX says the console is
moving it is successful even though we
seeing all these things and some
potential issues right is it a situation
where you can sit like hey we don't got
to really change cuz look you know they
going to buy it regardless you know they
going to do what we want them to do so
do you see huis what what do you see out
of all this is my question I already
told you Rome was burning a long time
ago this is just a dignified fact of uh
you're going to see it it's it's it's
it's you you're seeing the magnifying
does that mean Rome is burning you mean
he going break it down he going break
this remember the Roman Empire the Roman
know what happened in Rome but how does
it relate to play well well they're Rome
right now they yeah they're Rome right
regardless to what they what they say
moves in Needle they have people that
are literally can watch a buggy mess of
a situation and don't report the bugs
because we're not going to do that like
that's this is Rome we're going to hold
Rome up to a different standard this is
Rome if you're down with Rome is Rome
right and so Connie is Christ and they
killed her no no wait wait stop
that
no
no that was wild Jeffy no Jeffy
no no Jeffy
no no Sunday of all days it's Sunday
right you're wild Jeffy you're Wild
no yo stop it stop it now let's leave
that narrative alow continue sir kind
Crazy Jim Ryan why have you forsaken
me I'm done I'm done I'm done go ahead
go ahead he said he's pump his Pilot hey
stop
it now the thing the thing is is this
first of all I don't know how she got
tossed with this rock I don't understand
it yeah but I'm not internal okay so I
do understand beef right and they both
been there for 30 years right you they
could that beef could have started long
time ago and he know he out the door he
said before I go I'm sorry I'm gonna
shut up but you got a guy in the chat
that says Connie's coming back after
three
days out of control she GNA come back
after Easter continue your story hear
this be I'm sorry I'm sorry no it's it's
just the fact of the matter is it it
just seems like it like you said it it
was it looks kind of Petty from the
outside and and from and from anybody
that's close to it I don't know if every
day they was exchanging in glances you
understand like I'm not down with what
you down with or maybe she was like
maybe she she was down to this and
they're seeing the problems I
see this is their coid situation
Microsoft went through it they didn't
have games that were ready to go at that
period of time so their Co situation hit
them a whole lot harder in the beginning
of of the generation Sony had a lot of
PlayStation games and remember they
believed in Generations but then it was
like they had to pull that back and just
extend the generation a little bit
further to keep them moving yeah while
they get going right and at the same
time Jim is like okay we're going to
consolidate this that's the Europe stuff
we're going to uh move this away from uh
Japan we're can to condense this and now
we can do the pivot to the games of
service because we still had these games
that were uh keeping us going along at
the period of time they will always hit
that number that that number of a 100
million there's a 100 million people
that will buy these consoles right this
that will happen they have a loyal fan
base that will happen but that's not
enough that has never been enough so
that's not going to get them to where
they want to be the reason why I said
ROM is burning is because we're having
all this internal conflict and we have
individuals that has been at this
company for 30 plus years people that's
intrical to the DNA
you said if she's the soul and she has
uh been in places to help stuff get uh
past the line to to get stuff over that
edge if she's removed and you're being
hit with the onslaught of Game Pass and
large Acquisitions and games actually U
moving Microsoft getting that machine
moving how do you pivot how do you make
it happen where you can't make mistakes
this is why I'm saying Rome is burning
right when you say Rome is burning you
mean they're going to be gone oh here it
is jaffy here it is tell them King that
they can never be gone because of the
IPS that they have right I believe
they're going to be out of the uh the
console space yes tell him specifically
what you said oh ain't goingon to be no
PlayStation sex yes yes
ABS I stand on
that PlayStation no no always I don't I
don't care who you bring in front of me
um okay but that's not true true okay
okay so he standing on his making it
PlayStation maybe research and
development is fantastic until it's not
um oh my you know production is great
until it says no right um continue he
standing on this I respect it I've been
in places where I saw machines and I saw
death K and I saw stuff getting ready
and those stuff never came out never
happened to M2 you still waai for your 3
M2 me and Chip Hawk is and you me Us St
yeah we having lunch and stuff ah man we
have that story jaffy it's funny in New
York I can't wait to get trip here yeah
we gotta get trip on the show continue
but the fact of the matter is this I
believe they're going to make that
position at the switch over when a
couple of these games of service don't
hit right it's it's very hard to make
those games stick it's good that you
have the DNA with the Spider-Man I'm
playing Spider-Man and I'm like yep it
feel like God of War it feel like uh
Last of Us it feels like Horizon they
got that DNA that that thread that moves
in between those games that production
value it's high they I'm I'm looking at
Spider-Man so close on the screen I'm
like look at the detail it's so
beautiful
but how do you make that pivot to games
of service I see right they're they're
trying I mean they they bought Bungie
Marathon actually looks potentially cool
but Bungie is not gonna stick around and
you know it that Bungie has no choice
bung's owned you mean Talent yes oh I
mean who knows I don't know I mean Sony
tends to bung's a weird one because Sony
you know for all their lip service there
is truth that they do tend to acquire
companies they already have good
relationships with it's not like because
if that was the case Ted price wouldn't
be there anymore or you know I mean
Jason Ruben and Andy was gav gav yeah we
had Ruben on yeah I mean so those guys
stuck around I don't think they left the
minute their keyman Clause was done but
I think with Bungie you could be right
because I don't think there's real
loyalty right uh but the last four or
five Acquisitions have kind of not been
relationship based I feel
like fire bright you know that kind of
thing was firewall I can't remember the
other one but I I hear what you're
saying though say this unless are you
king no done do okay well no I just
because it relates to what you were
saying and Sovereign saying which is
this idea of you know at a lot of
companies you know you you know there
are enough redundancies because people
slide in over the years that you say you
know of course we can say goodbye to
this guy but this guy or this lady has
it right right who and maybe there are
people I'm just not aware of them but
I'm like you know I look at the Ries and
the booths and the drans and the Cory
and the the people who right now uh uh
and there's more of them than that that
you know Ted price and and all those
guys that are you know these aren't new
people who have just burst onto the
scene and it's like it's okay they got
the Hi-Fi Rush guy even though mami's
out yeah this guy's the one you know who
who at PlayStation as these people do
peel off it's even at Nintendo you know
mamoto is basically a figurehead for the
most part at this point but we can name
names of people that have come and and
learned how to make that magic and give
it their own spin what where is that at
PlayStation right now that's the does it
exist it might exist I may just be
blanking on names but I I'm like these
guys the guy who directed Spider-Man the
guy who directed miles uh and is
directing Wolverine these aren't these
aren't new guys they just picked up
these are you know this is this is these
are lifers for the most part with the
Sony relationship so uh if you are going
to push these people out um then what's
the plan that's what's next have the
other thing I will say though about it's
important to add to the one of the other
narratives that's going around is Sony
Japan I was just about to go there go
ahead
been pleased with Jim Ryan now I don't
know if that's true but when when I was
annoyed as a former PlayStation guy who
has colleagues and a couple of friends
still there um when he's like our we
can't compete with Call of Duty now yeah
I hated that statement I understand okay
but I understand
that right exactly you know but it
wasn't a good look but so what if he if
they would have killed the deal deal
that that is yo Jim is the
that's right but given that he's kind of
you know being kind of disrespectful uh
publicly as a tactic and it doesn't work
given the fact that um uh the
acquisition did go through right given
the fact that games of service um is
looking a lot lot lot harder maybe than
we all including me thought it would be
for them years ago yearsing the pivot
may have been too strong
and well I'm implying that
maybe Jim wasn't retiring to go see his
family more maybe he was oh King is
cooking right I don't I don't know that
I don't know that I'm just saying that
that that's another narrative I've heard
out there and it does kind of make sense
that you know you're looking at an
executive that kind of presided over the
Activision yeah yep not that not that he
could have done anything you're talking
about legalities and there were probably
a gajillion
lawyers he could have did a lot he could
have deal he could have took the deal
well wait a minute though that was the
worst negotiation tactic deal
you I would jaffy on
that take that deal let me for get Jeffy
cuz Jeffy if I offer you this deal do
you take this deal Jeffy in the
beginning deal if you I want to do that
Denzel lip quiver like I'm in the movies
and I'm I want to you know because I
love it when he does that then he
delivers a great speech I I don't know I
mean look um honestly what Jim Ryan
probably did he's not a [__] he
probably went to the lawyers of which
there are many and said talk to me about
the probability of this case going
through and if it turns out that they
sold him on the idea that no we can
totally block this um then I wouldn't
have taken the deal because my my where
I steer that ship is based on the people
around me who were smarter than me in
certain okay areas talk to talk to
regardless
regardless though it all comes down
though to some people like okay all
that's great but when the rubber meets
the road we don't have Call of Duty in
10 years facts and the money um you know
we now have to figure out you know why I
don't know if you guys saw that Eric
lmel PR uh dance he did when he was
explaining how people love the value
that ps+ gives yeah I did see that I
mean I I have ps+ it's fine there's
certain things I I love the trials they
do and stuff but it's it's no Game Pass
that's you know never and it's not meant
to be blah blah blah but ultimately you
know just don't say anything it's better
yeah but but but I mean ultimately the
rubber meets the road and he presided
over the Activision thing the games is a
service kind of pivot thing um you know
maybe Japan was kind of going you made
us look bad Jim made us been there yeah
okay
so this is the part this is the part
where they they had he I told people he
was going next fiscal period this is
when it started and they laughed at me
the only reason why I said that is
because okay we have a golf we we
playing golf me and you and and Bobby KK
all right so I'm Phil you Jim and
Bobby's there we playing golf and yo
listen this is the deal we want to do
this then the third we all here having a
good time and you say
yeah and and the conversation is good
back and forth between me and you m and
I send you the email yeah we going to do
this we send that over sign that and
then you come back to me with this chest
puffed out because you don't talk to
your
lawyer and now you know we gonna block
this in this entirety I don't want to
see what if they what if these people
told bro if you block they they ain't
GNA beat the FTC they ain't gonna beat
the CMA they ain't gonna beat the E we
could block it make up whatever you got
to say and and this is the wild part Jim
has no problem with throwing people
under the bus I you need to throw your
lawyers under the bus whoever told you
well the deal that that was on in place
and I I know Sony proper said wait a
second this is the deal we had we went
we spent all this money we flew you all
over the place we spent all all this
room service that you you Brussel you
know we hurting right now you did all
this food service you said we was gonna
get this blocked and you went all over
the place and this is the deal we so so
his so you are you implying that his
failure to block the deal is what landed
the situation so so they said you know
what Jim this is your last your key card
don't work this is the last one for we
we done with you we done with this and
Jim said you know what before I go I got
a problem with this
girl not the C fall out he said said if
I'm out you out we but you out earlier
than oh kid not like this you going to
be out but I'll be out later but you
gonna be out
now oh my God all I will tell you is
um
boy all I will tell you is have you been
reading my emails from certain sources I
oh King is on it oh Jeffy confirmed King
is on it I didn't confirm [__] I you
confirm I don't SLO SLO is it's
confirmed listen listen I know I know
people
too and the thing is when when it was
said
I didn't know cuz the way it was said
they didn't know if she was fired or
they Tred to keep that low right but
they was like yo cuz he was like I was
like oh one person left they was like no
King it was the team it's like the team
I what the hell is going on right so
then that's like right after that then I
saw your text your your your Twitter uh
text your post and I was like oh yeah
They Crucified My B for this so stop
using that word sorry apologies
apologies apologies
LA's day sorry yeah please I don't want
them you know picking and get me facts
facts be cancell yeah I don't want to be
part of that one I got my other stuff
but but then you know Jeffy you you
shined some light on it and not saying
that you know whatever but you gave some
context to it yeah I didn't like how a
30 uh year employee is treated in that
nature me my
opinion yeah ter see it seems Petty uh
you know the same way that I didn't like
what happened with Kima and I stood on
that uh it just seems like certain
things but I understand how Warfare goes
and if I'm out the door bro if I got a
problem with you and I got any sort of
control you going
first I got one question ask we move on
because I know we go along with this but
the thing he mentioned Japan I want to
go back to that and we haven't really
touched on a name too much which is
Herman right and H and um obviously your
Source one of your contacts you know
wasn't necessarily the big fan so you
would be an objective in in defense of
telling the story and the story had
reference to The Cutting of the Japanese
Studios and for me you know I just want
to know one internally why there may be
some that may not like him and his
Direction and then two we did notice it
solve at the start of the PS5 generation
we to me which is Iconic because King is
always imported systems and if you've
import it you know the X in the circle
were always the opposite in there and
that was like a Japan sensibility and I
remember with the PS5 it was not the
case and I remember some Japanese um
PlayStation PlayStation owners telling
me like this was disrespectful I can't
believe that that the shift is this
aggressive and then we saw obviously the
EUR European influence and stuff that
you know Jim was doing then where they
dominated in the PS4 era so one like why
do you think he's not liked in turn
again by this contact are you saying gim
or Herman Herman sorry Herman and then
and but I I'm I'm going to kind of
package them together because
I I don't know if that's valid I
mean I I don't know I've never met
Herman in my life i' I've heard a few
stories that make him sound like I
wouldn't like him um but I I I you know
I I I have not and I don't think the IPS
that he has lorded over in Guerilla are
very good I think they're beautiful
technical masterpieces and gameplay
masterpieces and control and stuff but I
just I think out of all of Sony's first
party big guns at an IP creation level
they're kind of the weakest and you know
I just think it's silly how much they're
investing in Horizon and all this stuff
but that's just my own personal opinion
but I don't hear that he is
uh your contact wasn't a big fan of him
well my the kind which one are we
talking about the one you have many so
I'm just talking about one that I can't
really get into I can say that that that
one was less was more kind of
saying that his beef was more Jim Ryan
and he was suggesting to me maybe that
uh you know some people may be caught in
between it's like like I got to do my
job and at the same time I don't like
what this person's telling me to do but
I got to do my job and so you know and
even like the the smithz woman who's
coming in Angie Smiths to I hear nothing
but amazing things about her yeah so you
know the there's no there's no real
stink on Herman Holst other than just
kind of some personal [__] that I thank
you for clarifying that no no I'm glad
cuz I I Mis interpreted you know there's
a lot of stink on me too so I'm not I'm
not it's not like you know this is not a
big picture issue with Herman uh I think
he might just be trying to figure out
what the [__] is going on you know
that's what I think I feel and F final
question in reference to you know Connie
and the aftermath obviously we don't
know her situation we don't know if
there's a non-compete you know um you
know again who knows if she just wants
to right off at to the Sunset and retire
like we we don't know what our mindset
is but I guess the question is like if
she is available if she has interest in
continuing you know do you think it
behooves Microsoft to pick up that phone
and tell us why why is this so important
I've been saying that about Connie and
roie and uh Shannon stud um for a very
long time and you know whether they've
tried it and whether they've been
rejected uh I don't know okay
um
but you know I if we go back to the Matt
booty thing like I don't know Sarah Bon
but she seems like she's presided over
some good successes and she seems like
she's you know she's it was a good a
good choice um and again I've every time
I've seen Matt booty on stage and give
I'm like he seemed like a nice guy like
I could really see him being a good
human being and it wouldn't surprise me
um but I just look at the output right
um and I look also at the you know it's
not like I could be wrong but I I
remember a couple months ago looking at
his resume uh or mobi games or whatever
it's not like he was ever I ran these
Studios and I shipped these 20 games as
the producer and he wasn't like the
finisher like Rob Ferguson right right
so so that along with the fact that you
can look at how things have gone like
unless Phil Spencer and Matt booty know
and Matt booty has been coming into
Spencer's office for the last four years
going dude you got to let me run and
he's like I will but I can't yet because
all this political BL stuff right and so
maybe that's what's going on but short
of that why in the world with all you
know it's like Phil Spencer's got all of
these toys to play with now this great
Orchestra it's like
dude there are conductors out there that
can do this brilliantly why are you
giving it to this guy unless there is
something like that we don't know so
yeah I think to get a Connie and to get
a roie and to get a a Shannon and man
you they would be unstoppable um and I'm
not saying they won't be in the future
without them I'm just saying that to get
that institutionalized knowledge of what
it takes to really run uh internal and
external product development when you're
talking about really creative people
right that's the trick right you it's
easy to manage people that are soulless
that you can just kind of tell do it or
you'll lose your job but when you've got
these people back in the day like me or
Corey or dman or uh Brian at at
Insomniac or TI these are you know
they're Alphas yeah you know not you
know uh and so you've got to find a way
to make that work in a way that they
still get what they want but you also
benefit from them financially for the
company right that's not easy um and you
also got to know when to call BS on BS
and a lot of these including me would
give a lot of BS and it's like okay
that's great but this is the one time
I'm putting my foot down you know made
you mad but you're like yeah get it you
idiot but it got it done um right so yes
I think it you know I don't know about
non-competes and all that um but I think
absolutely if they haven't reached out I
can't fathom why unless like I said
maybe Matt booty is gonna end up heard
I've heard good things internally but
from the Midway days and I can just talk
about what I've heard which is that a
lot of them not being able to hit the
ground running and go in the way that
you're you're talking about a lot of it
has to do with this structural from from
what I hear ABK really hamstrung them
and from what they were able to do and
now we're seeing this organization they
were having they were having well before
also like I look this is what I look at
I look at like the situation like red f
right and that to me that's atrocious
that should never happen right there's
no way a game like that should come out
in that state and to me it's like well
what do you mean you didn't know how it
was going down you know what I'm saying
like what that kind of thing so to me I
see a disconnect especially to your
point the more you acquire the more
you're going to have to manage and yeah
to me when I judge Matt and this is just
my personal opinion I could be wrong I
look at the 2018 draft class so to speak
right and I say okay let's see how Fable
comes out let's see how this hellblade
comes out to me that's again a lot of
what he's a part of in managing and I
need to see results there and then I'll
give a final okay you know you really
did that how long are you going to give
him to put out some games these games
are Tak a long bro these these games
ain't three years no more these games
are five years jaff like at least and
then you talk about a pandemic like we
got to be real even Sony themselves like
their first party lineup every game has
been delayed for the most nothing has
really shipped on time based on the
climate that's all I'm saying but
continue I no I'm just I'm saying those
are valid reasons to you know be
staggered in the ring but
but they couldn't come up with anything
for a while they I mean you know there
there's a point where you kind of go
okay well if we've got the money to
spend 70 billion on Activision we can at
least go out and acquire uh oh couple
exclusives for our B you know that
wouldn't have been Matt necessarily but
it's just like there's a point where yes
there are excuses but it's like okay but
get it that's not my problem yeah yeah
no no I get it I get it I get it I
completely get where you come from but
but no I mean maybe he's going to be
awesome maybe he's going to once
whatever the reason that's been holding
him back the other thing I'll say about
Xbox that I I I said recently I was on
uh uh uh Gaz and and col show we were
talking about um you know I
think they are historically poor it IP
creation um and I don't mean like I mean
Tim Schaefer's a genius I love Tim
Schaefer but Tim Schaefer stuff has
always been you know quirky enough to
not really hit the Zeitgeist in a in a
big way but you know
Cliff lazinski is basically basically
begging I mean I'm not saying he is no
to come back yeah assessment of his
Twitter you know if they called him and
said dude come in and work with us on IP
creation I'm not saying give him cart
blanch the team's going to want control
and all that course course but they must
recognize that as a deficit that Sony
just has in Spades the idea of just like
car I mean if you look at avowed and
Fable um me even uh hellblade I know I
know that you know oh she's a beloved
character mental illness and all that
stuff but there's just there's no real
connection to these Brands it's not like
people like I can't wait for the uh
Wasteland 3 movie I thought Wasteland 3
was brilliant but I don't remember any
of the lore characters for the most part
it's just kind of roll your own I think
they need that badly me and you are on
the same page that that's L like the
Xbox is mad at me because I literally
they purchase that no I get that but I I
no no where did they purchase it well
they purchased it thank you Sony for
building up crash thank you no yo
stupid crash ain't what he used to be
crash isn't isn't a modern you know he's
not him great again I consider the style
of game that is that is hellblade but to
jaffy point where I completely agree
with him is that's why I came up with
the hashtag just one moniker which is I
want a new IP new IP not nothing that's
a sequel or remake something that you
created that's new that's the new
protagonist for the new generation right
that's not named gears and it's not
named Halo it's the new face that's
created from your internal Studios that
has the high gra graphical Fidelity that
has what about high five rush I mean no
that's great but I we would we consider
that's it's a art artsy cool unique
rhythm game that's not what what I
consider like a massive you know
production you need like a big summer
blockbuster mentality when we started
God of War I Shannon and I were like we
want to make a franchise not a game when
started gears he said the same thing I'm
almost certain when Amy started
Uncharted and Neil took over on Chan La
they they weren't
thinking you know I'm not saying they
weren't focused on the one game they
were making but we all had delusions of
grandeur that sometimes worked and
sometimes didn't because that's just
kind of what you know maybe it's the
nature of working out of Los Angeles or
something but we wanted to be you know
we wanted to have that kind of success
where you're getting phone calls from
movie studios and going to the premieres
and all that crap you know and that's
what it takes to build and I don't think
Xbox needs all of that think don't get
rid of and I agree with you and this is
what I want to clarify I want to clarify
Halo either facts I want to clarify this
and when I say this again I think their
strategy currently is sound with the
diversity in the lineup in the genre I
don't want a whole bunch of just ones
you know what I'm saying kind of thing I
I just want one of them that's all it is
but I think they're capable and I think
it will happen but I'm with you they
need that Ze move the it happens oh you
don't think it happens okay I don't
think it happens for this all right
break it down I don't think it happens
because of the climate of making a
mistake right I don't think we're in the
space anymore where like where jaffy and
them was at where that that that
creative mind that we're going to be
this big thing we're going to make this
happen I think the industry has arrived
to a point where it's just trying to
sustain itself where these dudes was
building it you Jeffy you and your teams
you guys at Sony built this uh our
medium right you you like you see helped
yeah well you no no because you know
looking back at the stuff you guys were
the heartbeat happening at that time
right so you know gears and all that
other stuff yes y y' guys help build it
so when you get too big and you're at
the top sometimes you play not to lose
instead of playing to win and I don't
think Microsoft is at the position where
they playing to win I think they're
playing not to lose they acquire all
these uh franchises I think they're GNA
start going into the those decks get
they play dominate they the cash bro
listen don't don't don't get a Twist I
think they're G to go and go through all
the licenses and continue what's there
there's nothing
there I don't think I think prototype
and stuff like that is there no no no
I'm not talking about their stuff I'm
talking about the stuff that they
purchased but even that what did they
purchase you say uh
prototype I think that's a great game I
didn't disagree that it's a great game
but nobody's walking around dressed up
as the Prototype guy for Halloween never
has been but you make it cool Bas on but
based on what then at that point all
you're building off of is a foundation
of a couple hundred thousand people that
maybe remember prototype that's not like
you don't you don't build off something
like that why what the value of it
you're just going to upset probably half
of those 100,000 and you might as well
start something brand new that you go
out and hire James Cameron and come in
and say give us our superhero that's the
creative in you well yeah and that's
what and that's that's what's needed
right right I want to see the creative
and I don't like I don't hear new IPS
okay like I you know I hear okay
Spider-Man 3 okay uh we're working on
Wolverine an extension of that same
world or from I'm talking about from all
of them I'm talking about all of them
Xbox is in the perfect position I don't
know if you I'm sure you guys did I
thought it was great if you guys played
hivebusters is amazing it was a great
game 4our little thing you know
obviously they were building off stuff
they have to go into a team I mean even
if it's a new character in Gears and
having it done by Coalition or whoever
and just say look Our Big Game Pass game
of May is going to be like another
hivebuster scale game but we're going to
do those a couple times a year and we're
going to try to grow some IP that people
fall in love with and then they can
become you know it's almost like the the
the sort of farm leagues in baseball
right they can become the next big thing
uh there that's that's a perfect way to
sort of be safe enough so you don't you
know bet the farm but at the same time
you know be trying to figure out where
your next big franchise is coming from
so I mean I would I would love to see
them and Playstation do that but I agree
and I yeah I I think gay pass affords
them that the studios that's been
acquired because one thing about
creatives is what I like that I am
hearing is that they're saying hey we
want to go to you and we want to know
what you want to make cuz the last thing
people want to do is be on a factory or
assembling line you know what I'm saying
just forced to kind of create that same
thing over and over and over again so at
least that gives me hope that the
direction is at least in the right way
and I hope they do that I hope that they
do that I hope we get more high-fi
rushes I hope we get stuff like that you
know with the creative uh allowing that
ability that flexibility and that
freedom to to bring new IPS to the table
do I see it I don't think so but for
that no but I appreciate man I know we
beat this thing to death we got to move
on so we got any Super chats or yeah we
got a couple
okay let's see we
got we only got a 400 likes and we got
over a thousand people watching like but
we got David jaff man God of War come on
man we got a legend in here what's wrong
with y'all no they don't they you know
what have you done for me
lately coming out with a new IP we going
my new my show watch the exactly gabin G
forgot to I forgot to shout this out too
shout out to the to the uh to the
different uh Outlets out there those who
acknowledged that what jaffy said was
news and then others who decided to Oh
Be obviously because of the source we're
like oh no we're not going to we're not
super chat or are you saying No this is
me saying this it's
talk I forgot to mention that news I
don't want to be a reporter like I said
I hear you The Insider you you're The
Insider now you get all the do exactly
but but I hear you but when when certain
Outlets just decide like it didn't
happen yeah just because you said it you
said it well I mean it was for them it
was one source if you're a good
journalist I would like to think you
don't go off One Source that's what I I
hear that but for you to come out and
say it you know they could say whatever
you know whatever the internet is
whatever A lot of them don't like me and
that's fine that's what and that's what
I'm that's what I'm getting at that's
what have a guy reach out to me from a
site I won't name he wanted to talk
about the Connie thing and the whole
opening was like okay I if you tell me
to [__] off I get it if you tell me to
go pound Su you been do it good though
you all fire yeah and uh I'm just saying
so they they you know they know I know
and it's it's whatever they I'm I'm I I
don't care I
we got to give you your flowers that's
it well I appreciate it no doubt we got
David hotti $10 Super Chat second Super
Chat for Jaffrey to make up for that
crazy one what the hell I forgot
somebody I remember that yeah okay then
we have God Emperor sua King $2 Super
Chat bung is for the streets she about
to walk yo we'll see we'll see then we
have Mr two opinionated $2 Super Chat
sounds like she should have been the new
boss referring to Connie yeah mhm and
they was making sure that was not
happening then we have Jenna Hayes $5
Super Chat Starfield bugs weren't called
out by Xbox
leadership okay that whole narrative is
dumb though Starfield I loved Spider-Man
I
loved I said this on on Gaza show when a
game comes out that's loaded with bugs
like
cyberpunk you know it gets paid
attention to and it gets reported and it
dings the reviews and it hits the stock
of CD project red and in the case of
cyberpunk they literally pulled it off
the store when it comes to PlayStation
scarfield is not a buggy mess and
Spider-Man is not a buggy mess are there
bugs sure but that whole narrative that
that PlayStation got a pass and Xbox got
a pass it's like come on they go hard
you got to go hard I'm telling you they
go hard right now they you can go hard
but you can't go hard if you're wrong
going hard means you're aggressive and
you're right they're just making crap up
let me let me ask you this the the talk
is now that um if the review was already
made and then users are now playing a
game that is significantly less quality
should the review be lowered is the
question that talk about if it turns out
that after a day if the game they
reviewed is not the game that went on
sale right then yeah I I would think
it's a good responsibility and I I do
think sites do this to say update uh you
know since we wrote Our review which was
based on this code uh the updated code
from day one patch has changed XYZ and
in that we want to adjust our score good
or bad sure yeah that that's that's a
lot of the conversation right now so
yeah that's that's what it is but anyway
continue off then we have Lord roughness
Super Chat in 2023 it would hurt my
heart to spend 70 pounds on a game on
Friday and finish said game on Sunday
Starfield play time to date 255 hours 10
days and 15 hours
total it's up to you I'm having fun with
Spider-Man I mean it's an inconvenience
on certain things but again I told you I
love good story and this story is great
how how they how they made the suit how
how they're telling the story from the V
villains perspective how they how they
love and treated Craven I always told
people he was probably one of my my best
Spider-Man villains that was never
treated right and you know I tell people
if you ever want a good story go to get
uh Spider-Man's Craven's last hunt I
think Mark baggley did the artwork it
was probably mantis yeah yeah it was the
best Craven storyline uh to date and
they use some of that here in this and
it's an incredible story I I can't
stress it enough that I don't care what
side of the fence you're on the spider
side of a
fence be a gamer thank you Jesus Christ
sorry Sunday whatever what I good about
Spider-Man uh in that is that yeah what
I loved about it is it's paced like a
Netflix series and not a movie so I was
I was surprised that I had to get
halfway in to that game before a couple
of these big things that most games
would have put out in the first 10
minutes I mean they really in and it's
still the story is compelling it's not
like you're it's boring but they really
told it in a in a in a in a structure
that I think works for a longer game
versus like just trying to be a
three-act structure movie it yeah I I
think it should be talked about when
people talk about writing in games this
year absolutely oh yeah abolutely Contin
out uh let me
see Spartan 6615 Super Chat can we see
an episode of bear Gillis Bear Grills
with Jim Ryan in an era that he didn't
fly to talk to to Regulators I'd like to
see I'd like to see where he was scared
to go
to see continue addict old
house then we have yah baby fa $10 ja
just watch Dave David on Gaza show kudos
to him for being willing to Branch out
from gaming for a moment and have a
conversation about current events
affecting many peace to the Lords salute
salute salute the guys as well then we
have Vic the mother fing click2 that's
name shout out the homie you didn't hear
me say it before no I didn't I didn't
catch that that's crazy continue hit the
mother fing like button
you you
P's Vic from The Click all right I'll
see you that's it we're caught up all
right no doubt we going to move on this
one to be quick um XBox partner showcas
is my topic um just quick rundown that
went down you know what I'm saying so uh
obviously yakaza like a dragon infinite
wealth had like kind of like an animal
crossing mode show I forgot it's like
don don Doo Island we had that we had
um shout out to Future lab they had aaro
will not die that reveal uh still wakes
the Deep kind of the all rig game
haunted kind of deal um we had uh
developer Ton's RoboCop the uh Rogue
City you know what I'm saying I buy that
for a dollar old school Vibes you know
what I'm saying they had that joint um
dungeons of hinterberg which was they
actually played at px West that's the um
kind of cell shaded actually saw you
were with me we yes yes we covered that
game was it did you like it I felt the
control was a little weird to me because
it didn't have a jump button and I
didn't realize it was yeah it was very
uh puzzle puzzle heavy I thought it was
going to be more I I was completely came
in with the wrong mindset on what the
game was and the game is like extremely
puzzle heavy you talking about uh no
no King does not like the art direction
of the noses say that King was going
hard on the stream about the noses on
the game but I I I feel they they know
they nose a lot I will say this the
puzzles had me the developer had to keep
helping me he's like look all right you
might want to do this over here cuz you
the puzzles was a little confusing but
once I got the rhythm of it and then the
combat it's a weird Direction I got to
see how it lands I was in the Middle
with it but a lot of potential um Spirit
of the north uh part two so that looks
like that's coming um Sequel and um got
the little bir campaign with the fox uh
metal gear solid uh green triangle the
uh Snake Eater green triangle that's
what they call it here the green
triangle you know what I'm saying we got
that there and then manner Lords was
shown little city building in-depth
tactical battles the finals um kind of
like a say games of service game show
kind of vibe you know multiplayer
actually going look kind of cool do
heavy destruction from the a lot of the
guys did
battle but I hear it's just okay yeah
you can play it's it's available right
now to play open ba open Beta this
weekend so you can play it and I was
getting when it was funny when you said
Battlefield when I was watching people
telling me that I was thinking remember
when they came up with Levolution and
the destruction of the building and I
was getting that energy from it for
whatever reason because they were
destroying a lot of stuff yeah Arc
survival ascended um looked kind of good
you know what I'm saying as far as the
um new engine and of course they ended
it off with Allen wake to which released
obviously the same week so thoughts
jaffy let's start with you um Xbox part
yeah the biggest thought that I walked
away from was just how fundamentally
Game Pass has
changed my responses to announcements
because I was watching it and I was like
okay if if it had Game Pass day one at
the beginning I was like oh I'll try
that but the ones that didn't I was like
there was nothing I saw like I played
the RoboCop demo I'm like it's Game Pass
I'll play when it's on Game Pass if it's
not I'll probably never play it um you
you know uh so there were a couple of
day one game pass games I think they had
uh the towers or the the noas game that
you were calling is uh what's it
hindberg of hind day one but now that
you I probably won't play it now that
you've said what you've said I mean I'll
wait I'll see the give it a shot give it
a shot there's too much to play now much
to play not back in the day where it's
like I'll play that on my off time there
is no off time I can't play Allan Wake
right now that's how bad is in a great
way um but but so that was a day one and
then
um uh I was surprised that the whatever
whatever his name is will not die that
seemed like you're going to charge for
that yeah you know so that's that I I'll
wait and sees good developer though
really good developer um what was the
other day one game pass um Still Still
wakes the Deep the um the horror I'm
interested in that because I love that
genre horror you love horror yeah there
was nothing about that trailer that made
me go oh my God that's awesome but it's
Game Pass and it's a genre I love so
that has me excited umy David have you
ever thought about um making a horror
game oh yeah I almost made one um yeah I
got it all down there um yeah but I I
just you know I'm if I ever go back into
games it will be a horror game uh but I
don't plan on it uh but I love so I'm
interested in that but uh that game uh
the still deep what's it's called Ste
wakes the the Deep yeah um and then the
other stuff you know Allan Wake I was
kind of hoping that they were going to
draw game pass because I'm like the game
comes out tomorrow and why are you
showing this trailer now said that's
literally what said you know but that
said though you know that was great I I
bought it um not on not on Xbox but I
bought it um but no I I I it was very
forgettable to me I mean and I don't
think Xbox was surprised that most
people would say that I it it didn't
feel like it was promoted to be a big
deal I don't know if it was just like
hey look contractually we got to get
these out before the end of the year we
said we do these trailers um but nothing
really stuck that doesn't mean there
isn't like a game of the year in there
but just as a trailer introducing like
even Arc I was never interested in Arc
and I was like okay if that was on Game
Pass I'd totally play that because that
was a good trailer yeah um and they
showed some really cool stuff but I'm
not going to drop 30 bucks on it um so
that's what I thought go here where you
coming from soft thoughts on the Xbox
partner
showcase yeah I uh again it was one of
those things where I kind of feel to me
it seems like they have so much that
they have to say um that it makes sense
to do something like this because that
if these games get put into a larger
Showcase with more prominent
games there's going to be no
conversation around them whatsoever so
at the very least separate them out and
and have people kind of be able to
remember them when they do drop a little
bit oh I saw that in this part in the
Showcase I saw a couple of minutes of of
gameplay of it oh this particular one
said it was going to Game Pass um a lot
of these also start out as not Game Pass
and maybe by the time you know they come
around to to launch they are Game Pass
games and maybe you kind of reintroduce
it that way so I at first I was like I
don't know I don't know about this why
are they doing this and then I realized
I was like you know what they have so
much stuff now that they have to figure
out time frames for and to find oxygen
for that I'm like okay just just talk
about it whatever and what I loved about
the format was that no Talking Heads
right it was just trailer after trailer
but at the end of each one it says hey
oh yeah go to Xbox wire if you want to
hear more here is here's a little QR
code if you time did that yeah this the
first time they did that and I think
that that was very cool because then at
the very least if you do want to hear
more if you want to hear the dev's
talking about it just some a more in
depth explanation about what the game is
or whatever you have that option but
it's not for on you during the show
proper so I I thought that was very cool
and uh but we'll we'll see if they
continue with this format you know how
many more games they have to announce
that they think aren't going to get the
shine you know when placed up next to
bigger games what I liked from it
specifically
um I did like to see let me see let me
roll back through it I was pissed with
Alan way because I was like this way too
much and I'm about to get this game like
jaffy I was like okay maybe it's a game
pass last minut drop which would have
pissed me off because I think I had
already ordered
it but I was just mad they were showing
that much of it you know two days out
from release um I I had I didn't get to
watch you guys uh streaming it live but
I knew once the like of dragon infinite
well I knew you weren't going to be
happy with I was let me clarify let me
cl cuz y'all know I'm the biggest La of
dragon fan they show me in the game I
didn't care like ichon is my lovable
idiot they had a dude that look like
King but again my only thing had King on
his chest they had King on his chest
they would represent King my only thing
was that the mo is probably going to do
well it's just that I know what the game
is I was just confused that maybe
somebody might get confused thinking
that that's the how the whole game is as
opposed to this is a separate mode but
maybe it's just me I love the game too
much I assume that was I assume that was
the whole game I thought I did thank you
see and I and like say jaff jff like I
don't like anal why would I why would I
not I didn't I didn't dislike the
trailer but I'm like oh they're doing
Yakuza but they're doing Animal Crossing
CR and to me I'm like everything the
game really is is so cool and I just
wish they showed a little bit of the
game in conjunction with that that was
the and and specify this is a moment
this something this is something you
could do if you want to right because
otherwise I had kid laughing at me with
icho dragons and King was clowning he's
like this is your this is your kid yeah
yeah yeah yeah they did you
dirty so after that I shout out shout
out to Diz man when I saw rest in peace
in cuz that was I mean d played this
game when it was horrible running rning
at five frases per second looking
terrible and he like this is the
greatest thing I know and he would he
would have just loved to seen this blow
up right that would have been that would
have been crazy for a minute because I
was like I thought it was two so I was
like oh I like they took Ben out of here
no more
dies I said that cost too much he's out
of here bud had to cut him out the
budget and then Rogue City Rogue City I
actually played the demo during Steam
nextfest and I was like oh that's
another one that has some serious raate
tracing chops so um I'm excited because
that's coming out this coming week I
believe if I'm not mistaken so I'm
excited to play that that was that was
very cool yeah that looked cool yeah
still wakes release date coming out the
week of early release Call of Duty
and yeah that first party the Xbox first
party Studio game that's what's up again
a game that's going to get buried um
it's a shame man that's classic robo man
so this is this is my take out Metal
Gear I don't know if you guys agree I
great I I looked at it and I thought it
like immediately I was like wow they L
it looked amazing right yeah but then I
was like what is it I there something
about it I could not place my finger on
I'm like 30 frames per second no not
even that I said let me see it let me
see old mgs3 to see what what it is
that's bothering me and what it feels
like is obviously you you you make the
game in Unreal Engine five the water the
lighting all that stuff looks amazing
but it really does look like they took
that game like when you look at re4
remake that is a reimagining of that
game from the ground up right this ain't
a remake though
right this feels like it is taking the
brand
new top-of-the-line technology throwing
it on top of that game and not not
reinterpreting the vision and it just
feels like it's that game at the highest
resolution with the with the best tech
on top of it and it looks great but it
doesn't it feels like it doesn't feel
like it said they said hey let's create
let's let's reimagine the identity of
this game like in a way that REM for so
it kind of feels like a little bit like
like the greatest remaster ever um but
again it's early they could you know
it's still it's just in engine stuff
it's not the full final product but
that's what I noticed like this is a
very true to the original product sort
of remake as they're labeling it and it
feels a little bit weird it's beautiful
it's gorgeous high res everything looks
great it just really does feel like it
is that game with uh the most amazing
cat of paint ever um and I don't it
disappointed me a little bit but again
I'm still excited to play it I I really
do hope the biggest thing for me is the
control stuff yeah uh modernize those
controls go look at mgs5 even go beyond
that and sort of modernize those
controls um I hope they do that but
again I I don't know cuz it's Konami
proper handling it I I believe and this
MGS collection that came out recently
Is Not Great like they didn't really do
a whole lot they really it was it feels
like a cash grab like when you look at
when you look at what being done with
games like the you know the making of of
karatica and stuff like that like and
the care that's taken into going into
the history of these games
you would wish that Konami would want to
do something with that with their kamami
is not about that they got rid
of people they don't care about that
they don't care but they they cared
enough to to get an outside team to do
the Castlevania Advanced ones and those
don't historically go into a whole lot
or anything like that but they are great
sort of ports of those games um in a way
that shows reverence to it whereas this
it's like we'll see so it looks pretty
we'll see fair enough fair enough King
Xbox partner showcase your feelings sir
now you got time to marinate more a hard
six six
PA is what it is
um lost on the PA to clarify six
what we going walk away from that one so
still a hard six it ain't going to
change
pause the fact of the matter is like
David
if it don't say game pass on everything
I'm looking at you qu ey a little bit
different a lot of games that y' was
putting out there I was like man that
would be nice if it wasn't Game Pass
like we just saw Sonic get slaughtered
in the streets because he didn't fall in
line like a lot of you games out there
don't know the formula and I don't I
don't even think Microsoft is knocking
on doors anymore with contracts like
that to get in here now right um maybe
they closed the Velvet Rope right maybe
they we got enough for the year thank
you and we just got to you know fulfill
these obligations with putting you on
our show it was the friends and them
show yeah and the
friends right but again if it was in
Game Pass it was a Game Pass show it
would have hit different it would have
got a higher number because you can
anticipate these games and you play them
at the Leisure you know you got at least
three months to play these games that go
inside Game Pass right you know ah God I
got three months I I catch it and
sometimes you look up and you see what's
leaving oh oh I got to play this
game and and it put the faar god in you
so I don't know I uh I would have loved
Allan Wake to be like and right now you
can go to your game pass and Alan W oh
that broke the internet yeah that broke
the interet
right like like David said uh maybe the
internals on this game selling is
different I was hyped for RoboCop out of
everything on that show I know I know
this is cheesy what out of everything on
the show I only cared about rooc RoboCop
look good though cuz that's all era that
bro and and if you like the movie what
the demo at least does well and I guess
if Sovereign are the ones who played it
but it captures it really does 8s and
the movie style the movie style the
actress the actress that plays Murphy's
uh it's her it's her like it's her I
Peter wer is doing RoboCop right oh
let's go I saw at29 I lost it you have
30 seconds to
comply I I just want I hope they have
that that that great go in the bathroom
and take the guy's hair and go
dick
pause I hope they got that scene itches
leave like
you understand what I'm saying
like triangle button you just press it
and it doesn't
that listen unless I'm I'm not feeling
this conversation that I'm hearing
around around RoboCop's dsls oh no yo it
is a real conversation that happened I'm
like what is going on here we got we got
to stop that's ridiculous yeah but but
um definitely the the show was a it was
it was a good show it was it was decent
I like the format I think they're using
these shows these these and we say
throwaway shows but they're not you know
no developers are throwaway um to test
different things
so the QR code at the at the side do we
need to have an extension to shows if
this QR thing takes off right do we need
to have the indepth after this you can
watch the in-depth or do we just send
them to it and it's available already
how can we use that and if this is
successful then maybe this is the format
going forward and our on the larger
shows they do have like a saraon or
somebody come out in the beginning to
present the show and let it roll this
one was no presentation they just rolled
through and it was no uh somebody coming
out in conclusion talking more none of
that stuff I I think at some point
you're going to have to ask go ask
though what is the value anyway right
because there's there's so much to play
and word of mouth is so because of the
internet now and stuff in in streaming
the games and stuff that that a game can
come out you've never heard of and a
week later it's the biggest freaking
thing right so a of needing to build
awareness sure maybe if it's a really
big game but like this game's spirited
in the fox or whatever the first came
there sequel I I never touch that game
but if it and I don't need to know it's
in development but if I open up the
internet one day and it's like oh my God
everybody's talking about this great
game I'll just go try it so there is a
point where it's almost like what's the
point of it really you know I know where
you're going I know where you're going y
I'm sorry K did you finished I was gonna
Jud no I concluded oh sorry yeah
literally the same thing look I want to
say first for them I don't want to like
completely destroy it because I like the
fact that they are doing more shows and
that it they need more beats throughout
the year as opposed to wait till E3 and
we're going to just overwhelm you with
very all these trailers and stuff like
that so I like a steady course like
during the me you know during the year
even if it's B size in that sense but I
do agree with Jaffrey in the sense that
they have conditioned us to with prior
shows to say okay there's a Game Pass
announcement okay there this what's the
value for the Xbox only guy that's
watching this show right you would
assume that you're going to get at least
a couple of Game Pass exclusive
announcements or maybe you have the
marketing rights and I think that was
the confusion for me where I was like
okay well who is this for like really
really because most of the stuff that we
you know we saw already like we either
we saw it's coming out or it's just you
know Allan week to you don't have any
association with it that PlayStation was
on Playstation stage before we know it's
coming out in two days so like maybe
they was going to do with some type of
game pass I got fooled into it I mean
adct was hyping ourselves up think
there's like one or two you know secret
ones that they'll kind of drop last
minute and it didn't happen and maybe
that's my own fault for setting you know
ridiculous expectation but yeah I
thought look it was solid it wasn't
nothing crazy to go about um I do think
that it need I like the format without
the token heads but I do think that if
you're going to do these you got to set
expectation for what the Xbox guy quote
unquote is going to get so while I look
at this this is something that you want
to do to fortify relationships with your
partners you want to get you know the uh
the beat out there maybe you improve
your relationship with remedy you know
by showing their game you you're you're
like kissing babies you're doing that's
how I look at this this is not for me
per se but this is like a marketing and
international thing and I just hope that
they build on it with more announcements
and stuff like that what I'm accustomed
to but that's where I'm at with it I me
wasn't I I did want to add real quick
though you were talking about you know
you and I both having that
uh Game Pass effect on it where we had
expectations the other thing and it
doesn't get talked about a lot uh maybe
because it's at the upper tier of
PlayStation Plus but the one thing I
love that they do that I'd love to see
other companies incorporating and I'd
love to see if they can afford it for
the price to come down on ps+ with that
thing is their trials because between
trials which are not demos it's just
like you get the first anywhere from 1
to five hours the game and between being
on Game Pass it though both of those
things for me are really
reconditioning the way I make choices
now and I I love that you know it's like
look if your game's good let me play it
for an hour I'll buy it if I like it uh
or put it on Game Pass or whatever so I
I I love the shift yes you know that I'm
seeing uh happening for sure it's really
cool no I hear what you're saying and
they used to do that I believe what Xbox
game preview was one of those kind I
think I it sounds familiar yeah and it's
like I agree with you though I don't see
it anymore it was something they really
started up they yo King chill yo what's
going on with King right now I can't
even do the podcast with my man looking
like this what's going
on keep talking I like what you're
talking about I can't with you bro you
doing the most but anyway U yeah that's
that's pretty much uh what I got and uh
I I agree hopefully they do more of it
and they improve on the format so to get
the final topic let me get get roll yep
okay we got some to Sage $5 Super Chat
Xbox have many new IP coming Indiana
Jones IO interactive title Contraband
blizzard to new survival IP Clockwork
Revolution south of midnight Etc yes
there's a lot coming yeah then we have
project Aries $10 Super Chat side
question when choosing uh a respect a
romantic partner do you choose Fidelity
or performance salute to the Lord's
realm and of course Mr jaff no doubts
lute performance mhm
yeah
[Laughter]
performance the man who got them horns
remember for 35 months Lord bronze much
love to the
crew just watch my Jets win the most
ugly game till the last 30 seconds of
OT what is Jeffy word then I just pinned
both of them I I was looking for my
actual mask but I couldn't find it so I
guess I got to go with them I can't with
them two I knew these two are going to
be messy continue happy Halloween that's
it um we are we are all right so I'm
going to set up King's topic clearly he
was the justess for the occasion God
damn this
wig so yeah this is uh King's topic um
PlayStation 5 Slim requires an internet
connection for its detachable dish Drive
um shout out to good friends to real Tom
Henderson um he reported it's been
revealed that the new PS5 slim will
require internet connection in order to
connect first posted by Call of Duty
Twitter Charlie Intel the information
was revealed in the back on the back of
the new PS5 box internet connection
required it reads and then it had the
additional it says 150 GB minimum also
um 90 GB download required to play
bundle available November 10th as
pointed out by uh also was pointed out
by digital found John lenman also good
friend to the realm shout out to John
lman those guys the requirement has
raised concerns about the longevity of
the console an internet connection
required means that servers will always
be needed which could be disabled at any
point in the future so uh King this is
your topic uh yeah what did you feel
about this um situation sir in the month
of
shober are you
shocked and what's going
on why is it shocking sir it now we need
an internet connection for a physical
device that's an add-on to a digital
device
you thought you was going to get away
Scot
free so you felt that need to to inform
the realm of this you thought you was
going to escape
it burning people says you got that mask
at
Walgreens no no I got it at
Walmart continue King but oh my
God people M I've told you it is time it
is over why over we have we have seen
the last of the bumbling and fumbling
that they've been doing lately [__] and
this is the best part about it because
y'all was super hyped for this
overpriced add-on birth
machine and y'all was just sitting there
hey you know what it doesn't matter if I
add it you know what I'm saying and I I
just stand I don't care why got voice
you know listen I don't care I'm a Sony
fan I'm going to do what got to do right
so like you didn't pay your internet up
but I got this thing and I want to add
it to
it you can't you can't I can't y'all
that is that how all white people sound
oh no they isn't even
white I that was my Scandinavian what
happened
here check it out so I'm at the point
right now nothing is shocking me
but internet connection for a physical
device to an all digital
machine internet connection yeah this
this is this is poetic that you physical
guys thought y'all was going to get
away yo y'all thought y'all was going to
get away I'm so happy at the fact that
right now if they cut off the servers to
your
authentic you won't be able to identify
with it so they they can brick it they
can rck your add on this is this is I I
I know I've never seen this right I've
never seen this happening to one
company this much bungling and
everybody's sitting there talking about
we're fine we're okay so so to you this
is the meme this is the dog and
everything all fire this this is the
meme I found a better one I found a dude
sitting there with a plate of food
actually on
fire yo all right it might be because
they just know they're going to make so
much money off the PlayStation portal
that yo yeah I'm kidding of course no
they it's sold out all over and they're
GNA continue to fake sellout I I know I
know what you talk I
know yeah but that's a dead device
walking come on you and I both know this
but you can't tell these people that
with I mean I'm not I'm not saying you
know people can people can kind of
generate a scenario as you don't
understand when my girlfriend wants to
watch Housewives of X I can still be
playing Uncharted okay fine there are
scenarios where it's valuable right but
when you go to the B though yeah yeah
enough to launch a whole product line
come on it sound like a passion project
yes yeah I mean they did say it is
eventually going to stream and so if
they are getting ahead of that then I
then I'm like okay that does make sense
right but but the way they're selling it
today why you would buy it I just can't
fathom
why anyone's gonna rush out and buy that
thing but you need the airbuds though
jaffy yo y messy got right now Amazon uh
and this is what I use to game I don't
don't yeah but they don't no those are
special earbuds that only work certain
device but okay so back yeah whenever
you get a trophy Jim Ryan will whisper
in your ear something he like recorded a
bunch of things before he left thanks I
love you bares
shout out shout out to games of service
um all
right so now you need the Internet for
this for this uh add-on baby device
um what do y'all think about it because
when I saw it I said this can't be real
but this Falls in line with the doubling
of the PlayStation uh Spider man to
count like do we need a recount here
because apparently they didn't count the
numbers properly with games industry
about B and those guys are talking about
as far as the miscounting yeah the
double dipping the double counting like
one for me two for you he was going to
try to find some way to sne this no no
we G to talk about those numbers because
those numbers ain't real the fact that
the console went on sale in September
and those games and they count in the
bundles so it's 2 million consoles that
went on sale so technically uh um Mario
out sold it with 65,000 in 24 hours
because they only sold 500,000 in 24
hours physical Sal that that's really
the number but the but they was on sale
since September with the console so they
counting that bundle that's not real
numbers
people but I just I want to know about
the pregnant um Digital Drive how did
yall
feel I don't even know where to begin
with this jaffy your thoughts on the
internet connection required for the
detachable driver fast
live I I don't
care I really I really I I don't I I
think I think you know I'm not one of
these people that feels an internet
connection is a bad thing I think you
know welcome to life you know I mean you
know which is not to say there are
people who don't have a problem with it
and I respect that but for me
personally I you know I I don't care
it's just a you know can I play my games
you know I mean it's terrible I'm not
educated enough to have much of an
opinion on it it's just like whatever
some other thing I'll never buy yeah no
solve your thoughts on the detachable
Drive internet connection required I
mean it's everything requires
authentication right at some point in
time it's just the nature if you're
buying an electronic product in 2023
thinking it will not connect to the
internet in some way shape or form I
don't know where you're living because
it's just the it's the fact of it like
so it has to connect like what if it
needs a firmware update at some point
you just you just ass you're done that's
it you can't do nothing you can't do
nothing with it like that's what L said
he said maybe for for some type of
firmware also I forget how the
authentication works for movies and
stuff like that but you know again
Jeffrey's right this is dead man walking
right like we we already know the big
box stores are shutting down a lot a lot
of those sales next year stuff like that
well I said portals dead man walking I
don't know about oh okay well yeah well
D Blu-rays uh are probably not long for
this
world yeah they almost done but Sony you
know you got to appease the movie studio
still because they're going to still
keep making those things for a while
they are a movie studio as well so they
have a movie studio as well so they have
to so I for I think every time you put a
disc in an authenticate or something to
that nature so it it's stuff that has to
be in there so because on its own it's
not going to do it right that's DRM
that's possibility they all have DRM
they all have this now another thing you
got to remember this is an add-on it
needs the PlayStation to function so
once you connect it to the PlayStation
it's going to have an internet
connection there's nothing that you
connect to the PlayStation that won't
buy proxy now use that internet
connection for something so it's like
you know if it was a separate thing if
they did like a uh an Xbox 360 HD DVD
drive thing maybe you get away with it
as being this own separate thing God I
can't with can't right that but n i mean
over
baby bringing the conversation back down
to earth
yeah this is not a big deal not a big
not a big deal okay not a big deal
whatsoever I don't know first world
problems yes very much first world
problems and I don't know how many
they're going to solve but uh yeah I
mean just be prepared for it to to say
oh yeah it's a blue-ear drive go ahead
you can use it now that's it yeah this
it look I will admit it is a little
weird to me as a as an add-on you know
what I'm saying like um why it's
required obviously DRM could be a
possibility my question is is it a
one-time setup or is this like required
required well technically for the for
the drive to work it is a onetime setup
right but every time you chances every
every disc you buy now comes with some
online functionality like oh go online
and see these behind the scenes
vignettes or whatever or or it'll link
you to something else they want you to
buy so I think at some the thing
connects to internet no matter what um
but the actual authentication could you
technically disconnect yourself from the
internet after you do the authentication
and play a movie I think you can I think
you can yeah I think for me I also I'm
thinking let's be honest you know from a
from a security standpoint you know they
they've been known to be you know
obviously been
through we've been through the we've
been through the are creating we haven't
like we really haven't had we haven't
had a situation over the past like two
Generations really where we've had like
true like the
whole is broken and people are
bootlegging games left and right that
hasn't really happen right by creating
something like this you're opening up
the door for that to be able to happenly
that's what I'm saying defense though I
got to be corporate C for a minute like
they got to they got to make sure nobody
ain't coming through the back door doing
things you know what that dude that got
that CD
binder talk about he got all P PS5 light
up for you you don't want that guy to
come through oh of pocket I love
D you don't want that dude looking like
jaffy talking about he got the whole
PlayStation line up for you for
$50 we know dudes like these two you
want your information
back we definitely don't need that the
whole
system cuz we from that era where that
used to go down and devalue the whole
console yes tell the
truth what are you talking about yes I I
was around when those things and it was
and it was appalling back then
so s come out they got
us listen I don't know about Statue
limitation I know you
J you like no snitching no snitching no
snitching but look jaffin killing me
right now but at the end at the end of
the day that that's my thought I think
this is more of a protection Sony trying
to you know be a little safe uh I I
think we have Microsoft was trying to be
a little safe and have DRM and a box you
know it was like yo yo the internet is
watching us we can't know Microsoft is
going to sell our
information then Sony said yo calm down
my
son here I give you this what is this
this is to add on to your digital what
what I'll do with it you're authenticate
online
I guess we'll leave
it we'll leave it in the hands of the
Joker I mean what does the Joker feel
Daffy it looks like the jok is with us
he has nothing to
[Laughter]
say we all float down
here tell you what that's a lot of fun
uh that's a lot of fun to put on a
trick-or treat and uh you know hello
hello trick-or treat who's there not Jim
Ryan he got fire i d
you yo you two together are hilarious
knock knock knock who's there uh not
PlayStation cuz Rome is
burning I'm trying to save you Jeffy I'm
trying to save you right
now you out of pocket anyway that's all
I got on this topic cuz these two
together are out of pocket yes so
welcome to the month of
October anyway well Rome is burning
there you have it King K King with his
news uh S I would to get the poll we got
to Super Chat let's get him out here let
me see got a couple super chats not too
much oh see we
had sir duck member for 39 months Lord
bronze so does that mean the GameStop
can't sell use dis drives for the slim
month nope just reauthenticate that's
all if if the if there are any in
GameStop to
sell that we have Doctor Strange Love $5
Super Chat King asking for more
domination and submission with those
masks remember King the sayfe word is
fil yo yo yo yo
you hey hey hey hey
hey back to you
s
I think we'll end on that note that was
the final one moving along yes moving
all right let's do the poll cuz I don't
want to forget I've been forgetting
polls lately new ILP poll with oh sorry
pause pause on me yes that was wow pause
damn son why you have to do me like that
anyway heyo pause moving on with the
recent reports regarding internal
shuffling Within PlayStation which
direction do you think Sony should
ultimately take for their long-term
success the choices are eight Sony
should drop the aggressive Games servers
push and stick to the experiences they
do best B Sony needs to evolve and have
games as a service in their portfolio to
survive or C I don't care Sony and
Bungie still owes me my damn Last of Us
factions shout out to those who Rock the
poll it'll go up later on today and of
course salute to the legend David
jaffy in the building giving us the info
giving us the sources giving us
perspective giving us the comedy the
suit all of that and and sweet too's in
the building I think or Joker is in the
I don't know who's in the building but
he's still with us brother thank you for
coming back on the platform and thank
you for having me always good to be here
I appreciate it fellas uh find me at uh
David Scott jaffy games no David jaffy
games and that David Scott jaffy on
Twitter and I do a show and
oh I'm not taking I'm not taking this
thing off all day long you g put it in
the chat man again appreciate you
brother appreciate building with you
nice to be here nice always a pleasure
in real talk as men I want to say this
to you you know I really appreciate how
we I did it we're all men and we're all
together you wearing our our boxer
shorts
wait my mouth out loud I swear to
God I appreciate you because you know
Normal Man exactly that's that's what
normal real men do we talk behind the
scen and we squash anything do you think
Jesus will save me
if why he sound like this wild religious
preure the iron Lord's podcast uh Jesus
can I get
in knock knock knock who is it it's me
can I come in here no you ain't getting
in
here je got your mind all right salute
brother you you're a legend man we love
we love working with you and it's always
good to have you back in the real my man
sir David jaffy again everybody says
some love to adct man he's not feeling
well the boy got that yeah got that
robot tesser with the honey right now
you know what I'm saying working on that
cough and he was not feeling well so he
tried his best and U send some love to
our brother and then of course uh Lord s
where can the people find you what you
got going on a big shout out to jaffy
for coming through yeah love your takes
love your takes on on the industry uh so
glad to have you um just letting you
guys know that right before the show
went live there was uh a VGC reported
that there's a Nintendo patent that was
re recently repented that indicated they
might be going the way of the dual
screen once again for the next device so
just remember that I said that like two
years ago oh my god when everybody
starts saying that you heard it here
first you thinking you thinking clam
show what you you thinking well
apparently they
separate inter so now you could you know
maybe the second screen has its own
little dock or whatever what so there's
a patent what's confirmed what's
confirmed what it's a patent for a dual
screen device where the screen the top
and the bottom separate from one another
so it's it's like a clamshell when it's
together looking like a like a like a
big
3DS um but then they separate does and
then you put them together and they form
one projector the projector stuff
question I got does this eliminate the
docking of the home there's no there's
nothing here about a dock see that's
what I'm worri see this is when they get
too cute I worry that they get too cute
and they try to reinvent the wheel when
they got the perfect for fact already I
hope I'm wrong I hope I'm wrong it could
still do both things but you know we'll
see we'll see we'll um so yeah hopefully
I will be playing some Allen wake uh at
some point this week and more Spider-Man
and of course uh Mario Wonder no doubt
no doubt Lord King uh man of many masks
where can the five people find you what
you got going on sir you can find me
going to get gas dressed just like this
my suit it's gonna be crazy yo first of
all I want to say thank you uh for David
jaffy uh for being as cool as you are
facts um for showing up and I never
thought in a million years that I will
be able to share Airwaves with you so
the fact that you are um better than I
imagine they tell people don't meet your
um I'm so happy I met you when you look
like me you got to have the personality
can I appreciate it just say but uh if
anybody uh please go watch this and and
y'all know that I'm not a crackpot I
know half the stuff that I'm
saying and uh yo we did a good
shocktober facts uh uh listen Halloween
is coming up and this is this is true
facts listen you got kids um please
watch everything that they're eating um
the trick or Trea and stuff the days of
the trick or- Trea and is kind of dead
all right uh so be very careful with who
you get your candy from and who you go
around and stuff like that watch your
kids this Halloween watch your pets be
safe uh uh be married uh share in this
uh fun festivities we do it in my house
and I just hope that y'all do it but be
safe when you're doing it and please
just you know watch the kids make sure
the kids stay safe you can find me on
Twitter it's King David OTW is not Lord
King David if you're looking for Lord
King David you're going find somebody
else that's King David OTW on Twitter uh
adct and I did a great patreon uh
additive this week it was uh battle um
death battle and we're doing a lot of
that stuff for the patreon to grow for
you guys to go over there RNR with the
Lords with Ty myself and adct is in the
patreon and we're adding stuff we're
going to add the Round Table to the
Spider-Man spoiler cast there and the
same thing with the Mario Wonder spoiler
cast we're going to do a Allan Wake sit
down with um Sovereign adct and oh well
adct is not gonna be there Sovereign
myself I think uh KAG will probably be
there I don't know if he plays it but I
would love to get David jaffy in on that
one uh to to throw up there so you guys
can have some content and um patreon is
moving we're moving and this has been a
great month so hopefully next month is
be even brighter see you guys soon no
doubt you already know Sor we got a
couple more that uh super chats that
snuck in we got crazy horse with the $10
Super Chat uh the PS5 Blu-ray is signed
into the PS5 Slim So if your PS5 slim
breaks you can't use that Blu-ray player
with a new PS5 slim you need to buy
another Blu-ray player who
wow like if that is the case they need
to rectify that that is that would be
crazy crazy that be this is how you
trade
Blu-rays stop it this back baby you in
trouble
we have the10 diaku $5 Super Chat
where's the topic talking about sega's
biggest IP Sonic only selling 4,000 in a
week in Japan when Mario Wonder did
635,000 in three days hash where the
Sega fans at yo you better get we got to
get Evan B out the bushes he was talking
wild crazy told him some Sega fans did
not agree with that Nintendo Nintendo so
you got he he's missing he all we see
was de feat the little boy with the feat
Emoji running around so we got to go
find that man he was out here being
Blasphemous there in condolences to our
brother oh yes
yes Grand Pass and his mother was in the
carent please send your prayers love to
him yeah you been through a rough patch
this morning I saw the Tweet salute and
then we have Spartan 6615 Super Chat
David Jaffrey do you know if the yaku
all show Jim Ryan where the fish like to
sleep
haven't seen Jim Ryan yet haven't seen
him in months son I'm boy I if I had a
mouth like that I would be performing
the cunneling US on your
mother my God back to
you I like that beat I like that
beat then we got we got Nintendo deal
talk wait no then we have then we have
David jaffy with the $2 in the chat why
don't baby Jesus love me I know oh know
it makes me so
sad oh my
God Jeffy have you heard of a game
called I am Jesus Christ it's coming out
yes and I keep waiting for it to come
out I'm fascinated by it but it's not
out yet yeah it's not out yet y'all look
crazy then we have
nintend then we have Nintendo on the
otaku $5 Super Chat they're never going
to get rid of the hybrid model uh
merging their home and handheld
development onto one platform helped
them immensely yeah it it it is going to
be hybrid but I just think you know I
don't even know what's the next logical
step for them so going back to the 3DS
dual screen in some way they per or
always just made sense but again
Nintendo does things that don't necessar
make sense just do it into a into a into
the home mask then we have Spartan 6612
Super Chat happy Halloween everyone
watch out for cars yes be careful we
good everybody enjoy your Sunday again
the legend David Jaffrey the building
we'll be back next week that's all I got
again love the adct oh he's back there
we go
I passed out I'm sorry no no it's fine
it's fine you had the medicine in you I
already knew like that's what robot does
it rub you up kick kick King did predict
it but I'm glad that you took the
medicine cuz I know you've been feeling
bad this whole weekend brother so don't
even worry about it we we held it down I
am saying you guys a level one game
though cuz I'm going back to bed get
some sleep bro I like how he popped up
right at the end and he heard it
I'm anyway we up out of here enjoy your
Sunday peace peace
[Music]
w